Wake up.
Should fear be alive?
What are you doing?
You Tweeten you'll let them bitches now,
right now.
Yeah.
Is that what you're doing?
No,
he can't talk him tweet at the same time.
Very few people can talk.
I can talk and type better than I can talk and text because it's something about
using phones.
I can sweet talk and drive.
Yeah.
None of it's good though.
Never noticed that and focus on one thing.
You fuck.
You're doing all three like a monkey.
I read this book where it said splitting your focuses is just,
when they say multitasking,
that's just that everyone cannot do that.
I mean,
no one can do it.
You,
your productivity goes down in each thing.
Yeah.
It definitely goes down.
I mean people can do it,
but you don't.
If it's things that don't require that much thinking or complexity,
you can do it,
but if it does,
you're fucked.
Yeah.
This is the Joe Rogan experience podcast and we're,
this is my new character,
like no bunny talks in real life.
I have a unique pattern of thinking,
you know,
this is like,
I don't know if he's changed anyway through.
He's a bald guy.
It's a guy named Bob Scheer.
He calls himself Bosch here.
We'll have to talk about this on the podcast,
but he's fucking ridiculous and people believe it.
This guy is an alien.
They believe that he's,
he's channeling an alien.
That's how we told something like this.
So fucking stupid.
It's like emo Phillips.
He just talks terrible.
It gets me angry when people fall for really easy scams,
like really obvious scams,
everything.
But my friend,
uh,
his brother fell for it.
What are the Nigerian one?
No.
Okay,
let's,
we'll talk about that.
We saved up
if this podcast brought to you by audible.com if you go to audible.com forward
slash Joe,
they will give you a free 30 day membership and you get a free audio book.
Audible is a really awesome service.
A,
I'm a big fan myself.
I love audio books and I love their service especially they are on the cutting
edge.
And one of the reasons why I say this is because of their whisper sync.
It is the coolest fuck.
What does that whisper sync is?
It hooks up if you have one of those,
um,
uh,
Amazon kindles those kids.
Well you can,
you can get a kindle fire HD and you get it with the audible app.
And what it is is you read the audible,
audible,
audible book on it,
right?
You read rather the uh,
read the actual book and then it syncs to your smart phone.
So when you get in your car and your,
your will listen to an actor,
it's reading the book to you and the exact spot where you left off both together
thinking that's so it syncs up.
So like your,
you're dumb chapter three,
whatever the fuck it is,
boom.
You get in your car.
Chapter Four.
Bob Walked into the bank,
curious about their intentions,
but knowing that he had worked to do or if you start getting car sick or shit,
you could just like,
no,
we're just going to listen from here on in.
Yeah.
Copy written stuff anymore.
I don't like reading in the car.
I get,
I do get car.
So I was getting,
especially in the passion of seats,
if you don't know which way is like it's turning.
Yeah,
try reading a book in a car you can throw up ball.
It was a great way to make your wife on a is for people who love to read but
don't like to fucking read for themselves.
So have someone else do it for you.
And you know what?
I think you get the same benefit.
I mean,
yeah.
The,
the benefit is the exercising your imagination and the interacting with other
people's thoughts,
which enriches your consciousness.
So,
uh,
all that shit's available yo@audible.com and they have many,
many,
many books.
I recommend the war of art.
It's excellent and it's excellent for anybody who's a creative but is suffering
through procrastination and not getting work done.
Fucking,
it'll kick you right in the Dick and get you on point.
So go to audible.
What can I recommend a book?
Sure.
The road,
the road by Cormac Mccarthy because you believe that that's what's happening.
We're going to shoot each other in the head and each of his flesh and all that
shit.
If we get to that stage yet,
we definitely will,
but it's a good apocalyptic like real book.
That movie was too intense for me.
I want to recommend one.
Go ahead Ralph and the motorcycle.
Ralph in the middle.
Same amount.
A little mouse.
What does that just about?
This little mouse that rides his motorcycle around and he's a bad ass little
mouse.
Hey falls off.
He falls off the table.
audible.com have this.
Of course.
Most definitely.
They really look it up.
See if they,
yeah,
because we can recommend it and the look,
what the fuck word.
Boom.
False advertising,
Bro.
I had my hopes shut.
I'm like,
tonight I'm spending my time with the most on a motorcycle.
I'm just going to give you enough.
We do book and I'm kind of love it.
It's for third graders,
seventh graders,
seventh,
seventh grade only.
Look at habit.
Mother fucker.
So there you go.
The mouse in the motorcycle,
audible.com forward slash I remember
audible.com forward slash Joe go there and you will save yourself some money by
getting a free audio book and one free month service.
And the reason why they've given you this is because it's awesome and you're
going to enjoy it,
especially if you commute or if you go to the gym or anytime where you're
spending time.
We're just sitting there doing nothing,
you know and makes that like a way more
reaching time.
Look,
he can hear a sample from the mouse in the motorcycle.
Oh,
they play music.
They play music.
Hey,
do you think Beverly Cleary is dead?
Why would you say that?
Because it's been so long.
Just wrote that.
How long has it,
I dunno,
when was it we're looking him up,
Brian seven course.
We will be comfortable setting Mr Gridley.
Dropping some coins into,
man,
that guy's reading this as pants off.
We're also brought to you,
but on at.com o.
N n.
I.
T if you go there,
we're at,
we're in the middle of,
um,
organizing this DVD that we're going to do.
We're going to do a fitness DVD with me,
uh,
going through all my [inaudible]
kettlebell workouts because everybody wants to know Joe Rogan.
What does the thing you do that makes you so manly?
Tell you what is folks I was in fight against with him this weekend and that's a
lot.
What's,
what happened?
People would walk by and not in those exact words are pretty much going Joe
Rogan.
How are you?
So manly.
Yeah,
it's pretty much how people address me.
He's this new guy.
Mr Lazar got a boyfriend.
Yeah,
he's,
he's hot as fuck.
Boom.
Still alive.
Beverly Cleary,
96,
96 years old.
Live in it in Oregon.
Smoking reefer.
She's,
you think so?
Probably.
Why else would you live in Oregon?
Would you have sex with gorgeous?
Yeah.
You would live in Oregon cause it's gorgeous.
Suddenly even illegal in Oregon.
Really?
Yeah,
on it.com.
Oh,
and and it go there and pick up some Alpha brain.
Ari,
you should be on some right now.
It would help you,
sir.
Woot,
woot,
Oregon.
It's not legal in Washington.
All chill about it.
Bear.
Let me bottle of f Alpha brain is that one right there or when they won't,
they'll put you in jail,
son.
Don't be crazy.
Never heard of such a thing as this one.
We've got to talk cause you're going to go to jail soon anyway.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com pick yourself up some fucking exercise equipment.
We have supplements,
we have food,
and we even sell the BLENDTEC blender,
the blender that I used to make my delicious and nutritious Kale shakes every
morning.
One of the things that I talk about on this podcast all the time,
I can't stress it enough,
is take care of your fucking body,
man.
Eat some healthy food.
Take some vitamins.
It's all good for you.
And um,
it's,
it's important to do that and to get a little exercise in it makes you fucking
shit work better.
You have freaks.
So go there.
Get yourself some Himalayan salt or some killer bee honey.
That's right.
All right,
we have killer bee hunting.
Killer bee,
honey.
Ashley,
why?
Hey.
Hey broken.
Why do you have killer bee honey?
Cause it sounds fucking bad ass.
That's the only reason to have it.
It's a good idea now.
But wait until those bees want their honey back then where are they going?
Do you supply a fucking cell phone around them?
They followed the sky pussies.
I remember we talked to two that fighter about honey in Vegas over the weekend
and I'm sorry.
But yeah.
Uh,
Eva,
Eva Edwards.
Yeah.
What about any like curative properties of honey?
It actually,
it actually dries you out really quickly because there's so much in there for
the buyer process that it takes all the fluids away from your body.
So it helps him cut way back and then,
yeah,
and then they add the,
Oh,
I don't know if that helps me cut weight,
but then it adds it up.
That would make sense.
That's an interesting thing.
It's really,
I don't think what he said was scientific and anyway,
so that's not a part of this commercial replenishes everything.
I don't know.
What else does that mean?
If it did dehydrators
commercial,
you can't lie in commercials.
Oh,
he can get in trouble.
People like there's nothing in honey that does any of these things.
What they said is clearly a lot what they're doing is deceiving people.
This guy's pretending.
Well I don't know.
I'm just his friend.
No,
this is a goddamn commercial.
Is this not the commercial part of your show,
Mr Rogan?
Um,
yeah it's the commercial.
But Ari was high and he was just talking shit.
He doesn't really know.
He talked to Eve Edwards.
Edwards probably heard it from some fucking guru somewhere.
Don't know if it's necessarily true.
So don't use honey to cut weight.
And unless I wasn't there to cut weight unless it works.
That's what they were saying about removing water.
It just dehydrates you quickly because all your do people that cut.
Wait Dude,
just go into your stomach.
What?
Two people that copied to they deactivate themselves.
Yeah,
but it's not,
they're not pissing it out to what's going in here somewhere,
I guess.
Yeah.
It's going away from your throat and your and your,
uh,
the outsides.
Yes.
Thank coding.
Like if you're feeling puffy.
Yeah.
Cause it does lie.
Doesn't know what the deal is,
but I'll send you all the fluids in there.
I sort of find out the hunting.
If you drink water for your throat,
listen,
this sounds like nonsense.
No.
When you're swollen cause you drink too much.
Get rid of that by eating honey.
Yeah,
but I think it's soothing.
I think it's actually good for like injuries like scratches and shit on your
skin.
They can't.
It has.
I'm like antifungal properties.
Yeah.
It's,
it's also they use it as a preservative.
They used to store their mushrooms in honey when they had psychedelic mushrooms
and they would,
uh,
they,
they dry them out and they would store them in honey to keep it from going bad.
Yeah.
And they speculate.
That is one of the original ways,
and this is just pure speculation that human beings started,
uh,
drinking alcoholic beverages was fermented honey.
Oh,
it's called mead.
Yeah.
That's me.
Have you ever had meat?
No.
I mean either.
Yeah,
honey.
Well,
it's a,
it's people who've had,
you know,
honey try that though.
Used,
they've used it as a preservative for a long ass time.
It's a homeopathic doctor and Portland told me the honey is super great for,
you know what I just heard quack
homeopathic doctor.
Get outta here.
What your crystals.
You fuckhead no crystal clear.
Throw your Chinese herbs.
It's 2013 bitch.
Okay.
Get away from me.
I'm your fucking green powder and you're,
you're voodoo medicine.
Heard kettle bells in your life and become manly as fuck or I should fear,
do some cleans and snatches.
There's 60 pounders over there.
If in the middle of the show you just feel fired up and you ready to do a
Turkish getup at 60 pounds and let the world know what the fuck is up.
All right.
You go to shows.
He got it on you.
I had 20 pounds nvidia and that fucking shattered my knee.
You choose to add an interesting soul.
Ari,
he chose,
you chose this path that you're going through.
Yeah.
I don't know all of that stuff I love yet,
but I chose a body.
That's the weirdest one.
Well,
the idea is you can't see any basis for that.
Yeah.
The idea is that you came from another dimension.
I think just what she's trying to say.
I don't,
I don't necessarily agree with it,
but I see what you're saying.
Um,
anyway,
fuck all that.
The way to combat all that silliness is it gets a manly shit in your life.
Like some battle ropes,
right?
Go get some hemp protein powder,
which by the way,
Colorado is trying to grow hemp.
Now this is going to be very interesting because hemp,
you should know the hemp that we use to s uh,
to make hemp force protein powder.
It's very expensive and we can't grow it ourselves.
We have to buy it in Canada.
It's crazy.
The reason why is because it is not illegal and it's not psychoactive,
but it is not legal to grow it in America.
It's a crazy thing.
Like if you have it,
nobody can do anything.
If you bought it from another country,
it's absolutely okay to have,
it's not illegal,
but you can't grow it yourself.
It is one of the wackiest stupidest examples of bureaucracy,
government and,
and the idea that the people that run things are the best ones for the job and
the most logical representatives of the human race.
That shit is ridiculous.
It's not the case.
We have a bunch of monkeys.
They made a bunch of dumb ass laws and some of them are still in place and they
should be removed asap.
Anyone with power?
Obama would look at this and say,
this is not even a drug issue.
Okay,
Mr. Obama,
sir.
Um,
it's not even a drug issue.
Okay.
What?
This is an issue.
It's an agriculture issue.
There's an amazing plant.
Take away the whole weed thing,
throw it out the door.
There's an amazing plant that's essentially a cousin to different strain of the
same plant and it's not psychoactive.
And what it is is amazing.
You can make food with it.
It makes nutritious bars.
We sell hemp bars on,
on,
on at.com as well.
Now they're fucking awesome.
You can make clothes with it.
Superior close.
The,
the reason why canvas is called canvas,
the word cannabis,
hemp hemp is what they used to make fucking canvas.
Hemp is what was used in the parachute that George Bush Sr perisher does safety
with in World War II.
I mean it's fucking,
or was it Korea,
whatever it was.
How those wars?
One of those wars,
I think it was World War II.
My point being,
it's an amazing plant outside of the fact that you can make oil with it.
You can heat your house with it.
You could actually make a house with it outside.
The fact that Henry Ford's first fucking car,
the panels of the car were made out of hemp.
This is bananas.
Okay.
This is an unbelievably anything,
no,
nothing.
Zero.
You can make a pipe out of it.
I guess.
It's unbelievably wait,
rolling papers.
It's unbelievably useful.
It's an amazing,
it's,
I would say it's the boast useful plant on the face of the earth unless they
come up with some new plant that has an unbelievable regenerative capabilities
and cures Alzheimer's disease and they find it in the jungle until they find
that plan.
I would say that hemp is the most useful plant on the face of the earth.
And it's illegal.
I would say a furnace.
That's a fern fern.
Well that's cause cause you're trying to define it.
Um,
but Colorado is growing happened now,
so it's a really interesting,
um,
I'm really curious to see what he's a federal government going to rate them.
That's a good question.
We're going to find out because if they read them,
the rate of them for what?
It's a,
it's an agriculture issue,
it's an issue that really should be resolved because uh,
I think they're worried that it looks too much like marijuana and that people
are going to grow.
It does this and that.
Yeah.
It looks just like it.
So people are going to grow.
It just doesn't have buds.
The buds would get you high so that people are going to grow it and they're
going to say,
oh those scrolling up.
And he'd go there and they've got a marijuana drug business.
So since Colorado is making marijuana legal,
they're uh,
they're also trying to grow hemp.
Hmm.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
We'll get it.
Get it together.
America.
It's just some stupid shit.
I can't be the reason they're keeping it illegal.
That just is the reason because what apart that is the reason,
the excuse,
but it's also,
there's other companies that make a bunch of different shit,
including paper.
The reason why I was made illegal in the first place was a,
it was like a textile issue.
It was a,
an issue around me.
Yeah.
It was an issue as hemp,
as a commodity.
That's what it was.
They were worried.
First of all,
William Randolph Hearst was with Harry Anslinger.
They're the ones that initiated it through her snooze papers.
They just made up stories about Mexicans and blacks raping these white women
because of the pot.
They blamed it on,
uh,
this thing called marijuana,
which was a new drug that nobody ever heard of,
even though everybody was familiar with hemp.
So they came up with a new name for it.
But the new name wasn't even the real needs of marijuana before.
Marijuana was a while form of Mexican tobacco.
It wasn't even marijuana pot.
It was a different thing.
Oh,
so what do they have before?
Allegedly,
but what have I got all this online?
What would they spoken for?
Cause they found marijuana in ancient Egypt.
Yes.
So that you're not paying attention.
Marijuana.
The word marijuana was invented to demonize it.
Marijuana has existed for thousands and thousands and thousands of years.
That's not the issue.
The issue is the word marijuana wasn't created by William Randolph Hearst and
Harry Anslinger and putting these newspapers and that use the use of that word
to describe cannabis.
That's the only time they,
they used it.
Marijuana is a Mexican word for a wild form of tobacco.
It's not a slang.
Initially it wasn't.
Of course it is now.
It was not a slam dunk cannabis plant.
No,
I got that.
But when you said they use it to demonize this new drug will put it called it a
new drug or they called it marijuana.
They didn't know what they were making it fly that name to what they were spoken
before.
Exactly.
It didn't everybody know like,
well no,
we've already smoked that.
That's like exactly.
It didn't matter.
There's new laws now and there was this,
the first did it with like,
it was like a,
a tax thing.
You had to get a stamp and then they made it totally illegal.
It was like a couple of steps and essentially they took a lot of the people that
were working in prohibition and uh,
the ones prohibition went away for alcohol.
They just said,
well,
just fucking get these people to work for weed.
And they,
they just went after marijuana,
which was cannabis.
Before that,
before that it was cannabis.
Everybody knew what is cannabis.
So all of a sudden you're like,
wait,
what?
You're calling it?
What?
And now it's illegal.
And when,
when the people who made it,
when they voted on it,
when they made it illegal,
they didn't even know they're making hempy legal.
Like it was so confusing.
They were trying to stop this new drug that was just spreading across the nation
and whites were getting raped by Mexicans and blacks and it's called marijuana.
And there was like,
but,
but if they said,
and a few people are smoking cannabis and they're raping,
you'd be like,
wait a minute.
When did they start raping?
Like,
cause you vogue has always been smoking cannabis,
but then they describe marijuana.
They described like the lick the leaf of a,
of a cannabis.
Like how do they apply the two together?
What,
when you said late had this new drug called marijuana.
Yeah.
They just need renamed it.
But then how did the,
how did people think that that was the marijuana they were talking about?
How did they think that was cannabis they were talking about and not,
they didn't,
that's why,
that's why they made it illegal.
And they didn't even understand that marijuana was cannabis.
Right?
Oh,
in the bill when they were making marijuana illegal,
they thought they were making this new drug,
this new thing that they'd become aware of.
They thought they were making that illegal.
That's why they named it marijuana when they were going after it.
And these,
these stories.
So when William Randolph Hearst wrote all these propaganda things and that's
when reefer madness came out and all this,
all this propaganda came out.
It's showing like people taking that,
I want it going crazy.
All that was instigated because William Randolph first,
first of all,
he owned paper mills and the paper mills use,
they use trees and hemp is far superior for making paper.
It's a better paper.
It lasts longer and you can grow four times as much.
You can also grow it.
It replenishes itself within months.
Whereas with trees it takes years for trees to grow.
You can replenish an entire forest of hemp and a few months.
I mean it's,
it's an unbelievable resource.
So we ran off,
her son knew that he was going to have to change over all of his paper mills and
all of its forests that were filled with trees.
He was going to have to change that shit over it to make hemp paper now.
And the reason being was because they came up with a new product called the
decorticator.
And what a decorticator is,
is a machine that allowed them to effectively process the hemp fiber.
So the,
for the first time they didn't have to use slave labor,
which was like the only way they did it before.
And then once the cotton gin came along,
they were like,
well,
why are we fucking around with this hemp shit when it's too difficult to break
down the hemp fiber when we can just do cotton.
Cotton is not as strong,
but it's easier to make.
Then the decorticator came out and they're like,
look,
we figured out a better way to deal with the hemp.
Let's get back to him.
And William Randolph first was like,
fuck that.
No,
that's going to cost me money.
So that one cunt,
that one shithead,
the reason why,
I mean that's,
that's Rosebud,
that's there.
I mean he was such a mega maniacal cunt that Orson Welles made a fucking movie
about him.
He was,
yeah,
we ran up first.
He was a real piece of shit and that's what he did this fuck face.
So one guy,
him and Harry Anslinger and the and all the,
the,
there was a lot of people involved that were benefiting from marijuana being
illegal.
It's just like
when they lobbied now in the bill,
they said to get rid of this thing,
this new drug called marijuana in that no
doing,
who's trying to stop,
can't hemp because the new decorticator had been invented so they were trying to
stop pimp.
The way they decided to stop him was classifying it as marijuana,
classifying it as a new drug.
It was just a sneaky,
underhanded,
shitty thing to do.
Wanted to start it.
Is that what you're doing,
but just make reminding you that you're in a commercial.
I know,
but I,
I don't want to talk about this anymore on the podcast because we've talked
about on the podcast a million times.
I thought you already knew this story.
Yeah,
I did.
I just didn't understand.
I was only trying to clarify when he,
when you said he made up as new drug called marijuana made up the name.
Yeah.
But then how do people know that we're talking about weed instead of cocaine or
any other drug?
Because they said this is marijuana.
They showed you the,
we showed you the leaf and they showed you the buds and they,
they showed,
but what fuck people up was,
there had been people that have been smoking that shit forever and then farmers
had been using that shit forever would fuck people up.
I was like,
wait a minute.
The Popular Science magazine cover that just came out was hemp,
the new billion dollar crop.
So what they did was they went fuck that.
And they stopped that and they put the brakes on it.
That's why hemp is illegal.
So he's only allel as marijuana.
Only reason they're having hemp illegal.
Now it's for the same reason that only that they had marijuana illegal before.
Just cause it looks like the other thing,
the only reason marijuana was ever made illegal in the first place just because
it looked like nothing
to do with getting high off because in fact doctors had been prescribing hemp
the,
the edible marijuana form of it for remedies.
It would.
It had been in medicines forever,
like people had,
doctors had prescribed marijuana for people like edible forms of marijuana
forever.
There was no worries about that.
They use it as a trick.
They use that as a trick.
It was just ignorance.
People didn't know any better back then.
They snuck it in and that's the reason it had nothing to do with getting high.
It had everything to do with stopping hemp as a commodity,
as something that you can make cars with the Henry Ford car,
the first car,
you should see it.
He whacks the fucking fenders with a hammer.
It's this hemp fiber.
Hemp is like an alien planet.
It's the weirdest thing ever.
If you don't know about it,
if you've never encountered it.
When when you think about Pod,
all you think about it as like smoking and getting high,
but the stalk of the plant is like,
it's from another planet.
It can be that thick around,
but like a thick,
like a fat man's leg.
Okay.
Or not a fat man.
Fat Man's calf is what I meant to say like that.
Thick around and really light but unbelievably hard.
It's weird.
I get it.
There's nothing like it.
It's like this big hard thing,
but it's light.
It's fuck.
You can whip it around.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like if it was Balsa wood,
it would be that light,
but it would just break apart in your hands.
He's smashing on things.
You put a big dents in it.
Not hamp.
No.
Hemp is hard,
but it's light.
It's really weird.
It has incredible properties.
You make amazing cloth out of it.
So hard to rip.
Like I have a hamp Gucci bag that dot.
Sarah made me that Sir is a cool company that makes uh,
they make camp gies.
They make hemp,
uh,
Gucci bags,
laptop bags and shit like that.
You could have,
you could fucking pull on it,
man.
You are not ripping that stuff and it's not resistance to like bacteria.
Exactly.
Well it is resistant to bacteria.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an amazing plant.
It's fucking amazing.
You don't need pesticides with it.
It's just,
it's eating,
eat it.
It has all the essential fatty acids.
He sound like such a Hippie Douche when you go on and on and on about it.
But it's so amazing.
It's hard to believe that it's real.
It's hard to believe that it's a real situation that we live in 2013 and with
all the information that we have today,
that's still illegal.
And then there's a giant truck to park behind the fucking door.
Uh Huh.
Why is this cut back?
He parking right behind us.
We have a spot back there.
He shouldn't be parking there anyway.
That fuck face.
Treat everyone as if it was you living another life.
Unless they have a loud ass truck and they're being country.
All right folks at the music or it should be,
or is here.
Oh yeah,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N N.
I t.
Use the code name Brogan and you could save 10% off some supplements.
You're dirty fucks.
The Joe Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast by night.
So what was it?
The W we had said,
do you remember?
Do you remember what I saw?
So just save for the podcast that we were just talking about.
Yeah.
Hang on.
Do you remember?
Barely.
Oh yeah.
My friend who fell for the Nigerian scam.
Yeah,
he fell for Nigeria brother.
Yeah.
By the way,
this is ours.
You fairly,
as a gentlemen and our show,
here's new comedy,
special drops today.
Passive aggressive.
Where can you get it?
You can go to already the great.com you can also go to [inaudible] dot com okay.
That's the Jew.
I'm him.
Excited he got it was what I did all morning is what I did all morning and I
think Kevin v this morning.
I said,
hi.
Oh,
cool.
This guy's a great,
yeah.
Yeah.
There were way cooler than I thought,
you know?
Oh,
really?
You didn't think they're going to be cool?
I just didn't know when.
Anytime you tell me some,
he's been in the business for 30 years.
I just assume that means of,
and they're not gonna like me.
Yeah.
You assume they're old and they're like,
just add a touch,
right?
Yeah.
Something that's soft world of radio.
I just look at them as adults or something.
It's like you've been in some,
I dunno,
as opposed to self.
Yeah.
Or just the people that know.
People think of you as an adult,
you find,
I guess so you'll have middle aged.
Yeah.
Who Don't really have a grown up.
You're that you're middle age.
Fuck.
I look like such as love.
Yeah.
You're middle age.
If you're lucky.
If you're lucky lived in [inaudible] 72,
73 years old.
That's pretty good.
I hope I don't get black mold.
It'll just stay there.
You've got black mom.
It would be the end of May.
There will be no cleaning.
They definitely should do studies on my body afterwards to see what happens.
For prolonged use.
Yeah.
They would look at your apartment alone.
So this mother fucker is like,
he's,
he's a study.
It's just studying what you,
what the body can,
the body can deflect.
There's like 18 different toxins.
I handle it all.
Hold off.
So what happened with your cousin?
Your cousin got busted by the Nigerians.
My friend's brother was,
uh,
started getting real coffee to everybody and saying,
um,
uh,
you'll see real soon.
I won't have to take the shit anymore from you.
Whoa.
And just started being like an asshole.
And I'm like,
what's your story like?
I got a plan going.
I'm going to be a really rich really soon.
Okay.
Um,
if he was,
he was in contact with this Nigerian prince who was trying to get out,
but needed someone to transfer the money to for reward,
like v Scam.
He fell for the scam five or six years ago.
Not long enough where it's like,
you must be the first one to find out about it.
Wow.
Yeah.
Tim's a little brother.
It's what's hilarious is that he started getting douchey first.
Yeah.
Like that's how you're reacting to this money.
Did you see him like toll being told like the whole thing?
Like,
did you see how he just told us about it later?
But you know the way like Eddie Bravo convince them you're getting 10 grand and
he was getting 10 grand.
He was super nice to you.
He goes,
Brian,
you were about to come into some money.
Like that's a nice way,
person's way of reacting to it.
And then this guy's like,
hey,
fuck you bitches.
I'm about to be out of here.
You imagine if that guy actually hit the lottery.
What a content.
There's some people that are like that.
They were like undercover cunts and they're,
they're just ready to just like find a reason.
Like they'd been thinking about everybody for a longest time.
Yeah.
Did they just wait for that one opportunity to express themselves some?
I got it.
Nah,
you fucks.
Yeah.
That happens with a,
with actors.
Yeah.
You know,
we were too.
Melissa Etheridge is now,
we're talking about that yesterday about people who make it and then once they
make it,
they just act like everybody owes them.
Yeah.
Douchey.
Not,
I pulled away.
Just acts like an ass.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's what it is.
Undercover constants that I want to cover costs.
Yeah.
That's so,
uh,
when like when someone would be like,
I would smell something and somebody,
so he's a good guy.
I'm like,
he's an undercover cop.
It was just waiting in the wings,
waiting for that moment where he has the control.
You know,
he's that guy in the movie that,
you know,
locks the door and the monsters go and eat all the people that were outside.
I'm sorry your guys like you still have time.
It's like 20 week,
30 yards away,
opening the monsters in his room and he doesn't realize it always gets him in
the movie.
That guy always gets jacked.
Right.
That's um,
Paul Riser in aliens.
Do you remember what did he do in the early risers?
Best role was not,
uh,
not about you.
Not about Jews.
Paul risers best role was eight.
What?
He was the bad guy and he should've quit right there.
Cause that,
that mad about you was just,
he went from comic to aliens to then Sitcom.
Yeah.
And he was really good.
And Aliens,
he's a really good actor.
What was he like?
And he was a Douche bag in the movie.
It was just like,
oh,
this guy who was like ass kissy guy.
I'm so came from this company.
But then as the reality of these aliens gets revealed,
he's on this other planet.
As the reality of these aliens gets revealed,
he just becomes more and more mercenary.
And then,
uh,
you know,
at the end like I don't want to give them a spoiler alerts,
but
no,
he get his,
if it's been 30 years,
you can go on.
Yeah.
Well he gets fucked.
If you've never seen aliens,
it's awesome.
But don't get it in blue ray.
Why?
Because the special effects were not designed for Blue Ray.
Oh really?
When you look at,
there's a scene where,
um,
Sigourney weaver is being taken towards where,
where this ship is and they have the ship and it looks like shit.
It's because you have that true motion thing.
No,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
I mean,
it looks like shit because it looks like a painting.
Yeah,
I know.
But yeah,
that true emotion shit on dude.
It's sitting there.
It's a painting.
I mean,
it is a pain.
It's true emotion.
What it is,
is look,
they put a backdrop on some sets instead of creating massive environment.
Instead of doing that,
they'll make this huge canvas and paint this canvas or realistic like fighter
jet.
Well to in a regular resolution film of the time of like 1984 or something like
that,
whatever it was.
When aliens came out,
that was fine.
They would just put that up and it would look great and it really did look right
in those movies.
It was dark and dimly lit,
but in blue ray,
you see every pixel and you see that stupid painting.
I'm like,
I'm supposed to think that's a spaceship.
Like all of a sudden the movie sucks.
Like right away,
this movie sucks down looking at this stupid fucking painted space ship.
Like,
what do you think?
I'm a baby?
What am I,
what is this?
When they were doing it,
somebody was like,
people can tell when they come this way.
He's like,
Nah,
technology is not that good.
Yeah,
fine for 30 years.
Easy.
Well,
it's true.
Motion does that with a lot of movies.
Awesome emotion.
True motion makes movies a look fake.
But that's like,
you could see like the,
the detail of like,
oh,
that's just an old wall and some office,
you know,
like,
or how it's filmed.
You could just see the acting too much.
So many frames per second that it becomes really,
it comes really realistic.
And you like you,
you know,
you ever notice how like film things like softer,
it's like,
yeah,
the videos,
videos.
Like you know,
you're like a video on your cell phone when you're drunk and you make it,
you know,
it's fucking harsh.
Really harsh.
So lighting's really harsh.
Well that's what this is.
It's like it's better really.
It's like you see things for what they really are,
but unfortunately what they really are,
it's not that good.
Like when I was on a news radio,
the Sitcom,
they were just starting to use HD.
And one of the things that they said,
this is the nineties needs radio started in 94 and it ended in 99 [inaudible]
and I'm,
one of the things they said was that they're going to have HD and these
actresses are fucked.
Oh yeah.
Cause they're to see,
they're going to see what they really look like.
Yeah.
Because if they make you up right,
and they,
you know,
they do your lips and they put you in their soft lights and you're on a regular,
you can look pretty God damn good when you don't look good,
when you see them in real life,
they don't have like good skin or they're,
you know,
a lot of times they can really doctor you up.
Amazing.
So what do we do now?
Now they're fuck the girls have to be better looking if they,
she can't fake it anymore.
Yeah.
I mean people are used to really graphic high resolution porn.
You know,
where you see every zit on the girl's ass and you know,
and uh,
if people are in the,
they're into what they call a cream pieing which is the common size.
One of the first suggestion court the come out.
But it's like,
that's what people are into their into like super detailed,
just like really bubbled and gusting.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Why would you like bubbles like a straw with chocolate milk?
Oh,
sperm bubbles.
I have that projector screen now.
It sits like 130 inch TV in my living room.
So my,
my living room now is just like couch and wall TV.
That's awesome.
That's really awesome.
That's like the full interview old one was humongous.
No,
this is like that.
If that whole wall is just a TV,
yours is bigger than the one that I used to have at my house.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it's like movies,
like small movie theater is turn your head back and forth in order to know you
just kind of feel like you're in the movie.
I had a point,
but I can,
oh,
sorry.
Hey watched blueray porn on it.
Uh,
and it was so disturbing because not only was the vagina taller than me by in
real life,
but it was just like every single little detail like freckle and they're like,
it looked like there was like some yellow stuff coming out.
Oh wait.
Would you freeze framed and walked up to it?
No,
I never did.
I just speak.
He came out of vagina bigger than him.
Oh.
Taking pictures of yourself.
Have you not taken pictures of stuff that's next to a giant vagina?
Uh,
not yet.
I should be doing that immediately.
Dude inches is pretty fucking big and it's really disturbing.
Watching like,
like violent porn,
like asa,
Akira.
It's not like that cause that's just like so hard core,
so big.
It gives you like heart palpitations.
I'm really not into that shit.
I'm not into that hardcore stuff at all or I'm not in the hurting.
I'm not into watching like violent porn,
like,
like the hurting people slapping people,
gagging them and shit like that.
Like I don't get that.
You know,
I see plenty of violence.
I don't connect violence and sex.
No,
nobody sees more violence than me are right there.
It's pretty,
it's pretty rare that a human being in all of history.
It seems more guys get the fuck beat out of him than me.
Yeah.
And I've seen a lot of violence and a,
I don't like it in my porn.
Yeah,
I like it.
All I know for,
you know,
I liked head kicks inside the octagon or the Moitai ring.
I do not like some of them get more with head kicks.
Are there?
Sure there is.
That'd be like another list of porn.
There's some more than one.
There's one that Tyler Knight Fund and everybody that was on the podcast at one
point in time,
if you just watched Jujitsu at half speed,
it's pretty hot.
I don't think that's the point he was talking about.
I think he's talking about guys and girls,
but what they did was a,
these guys fought,
they fought it out and the winner got to fuck the girls.
They had like real fights.
Yeah.
Dude's got an organization called,
well,
um,
I don't know.
They made it out,
man.
It's some fucking porn.
But what often was this dude Aaron Brink,
who was a,
an MMA guy who turned to porn and started,
but so he's like a real fighter and so he'd beat the shit out of Tyler.
Wow.
I don't know what Tyler agreed to that.
He's crazy though.
Tyler is going to fuck that girl.
Tyler had like a boxing match with Mario Lopez.
You got to fuck right after you win a match.
Well,
I don't know.
Maybe they give you a little break and John,
seriously.
Well,
if the girl's hot horny and you get a quick Kao maybe we pumped up matches the
spoils of your victory.
You look at live in like,
yeah,
but people have to watch and the put camera in your face and shit get all kinds
of,
well you're coming.
There's other men in the room staring at you and you're like,
guys,
come on,
let me shower.
Are you in here?
Why don't I do this?
Yeah.
I did some web video once a day.
I was in a porno like academy.
It'll learn how to be a porno guy and know that it was,
it was like a parody and that slave from um,
from four at apple or at Bruno,
the little slave he had in the beginning.
I didn't see Bruno.
Oh really?
Wow.
How could you never see it?
I used to.
I saw you love Boris.
Yeah,
no,
I did love Bora.
I haven't,
I have it on DVD.
I do that sometimes with movies.
I'm like,
man,
I just never have ever took me forever to see tropical funder,
but I fucking loved it.
Took me forever to see.
It took me years like any bravo it.
So you haven't seen it yet?
You still haven't fucking seen yet.
I'm like,
dude,
I haven't seen it yet.
You got to see it,
man.
You gotta see you gotta see you gotta start the painting the alien ship?
No,
no,
no.
It was a inside a hanger and um,
they were all walking up to one of their ships inside the hangar and it's fake
as fuck.
It was hilarious.
I was,
I paused it.
I was like,
that looks like your shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
The dinosaurs from drastic park look bad on HD.
Oh,
did you think so?
Yeah,
I didn't think so.
I,
well,
I only saw the t rex film,
the t rex footage.
I was flipping through it the other night.
I was,
yeah,
the t rex when it first came over,
that fence know Goddamn.
That was a great scene.
That was one of
the greatest monster movie scenes ever.
When they realize that the electric fence was off.
Oh fuck.
And then they heard that thing stone.
When you see the glass,
like the wiggle and the glass when the thing started
and then it comes over the fucking Tom was like what the driving away from it?
It's running after them.
God dammit.
Who just told they don't think that t rex really moved that fast.
Really?
Yeah.
They,
the new speculation I think is that t rex is more of a scavenger than anything.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They speculate.
Even speculate that t rex might have had vulture like coloring,
you know,
cause we don't have any idea what their coloring was.
True coloring.
We just kind of guess they could be,
you know,
like look at like some of the,
the variation in lizards.
It's amazing.
So your fancy swapped together.
I have video of the t rex has with different types of coloring to the song.
True colors by Cyndi Lauper.
I see a slow down in Jujitsu.
It's bye.
Bye.
I need to find out what this,
what these photos of this fucking t rex looked like because I'm pretty sure that
they,
they believe that t rex was a scavenger.
Tate just told me about some tee shirt that showed the t rex doing pushups and
it's just,
yeah,
no,
it's a t rex.
It's on Facebook.
He said,
oh,
it's like a photo.
Let's go around the t rex.
His face as his nose is touching the ground arms can't just push a ridiculous t
rex.
Cavender look like while we're looking this up,
why don't you take an opportunity to go get my new special,
passive aggressive and where can they get it?
Could they get it already?
The great.com.
You can find a link there.
That banner right@thetoporyoucangostraighttochill.com slash Ari Shaffir do you
have a foe?
Um,
a um,
uh,
on your,
what do you have Ari?
shaffir.com is the website as well.
Yeah.
So you all that it doesn't change her same place or vice versa.
See,
this is,
um,
the new images of t rex.
They wanted him to be.
They think he's more likely read.
Oh,
like a vulture.
This is like some scientists speculation.
Well I saw it though.
Um,
some scientists have speculated this whether they're right or not.
Wow.
Who's trying to find out some new stuff about dinosaurs?
There's dudes that are obsessed with dinosaurs and then they are completely
obsessed.
They think Jurassic Park is like,
they're all time like bone movie.
Oh yeah.
But you know the really issuing important the real issue with like a something
like a Jurassic Park.
Yeah.
Is that seems like something we would do.
Oh yeah.
It really does.
I think we should do that would be amazing.
Well the only reason why I say yes is because you see Erc that Apache helicopter
footage and shit they can do with those things now.
The dinosaurs would be fucked if we really want to Jack,
we just fly around churches,
judge,
judge g,
we'd cut
those bitches out of the sky like it was nothing.
Just make a few t rex is cut their balls off when they're babies make a few
can't breathe.
The electricity's not going to go off.
You end up getting four or five generators and even if it does,
we just make a bomb and drop it on them.
Yeah.
With a glider people died.
He have a,
I have a couple of years,
I'm sure maybe more people die from hammers than guns.
All right.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
a lot more.
Uh,
hundreds of more.
Don't people die from hammers,
them cons or is there a very effective way to kill people that are close to you?
They're right there.
If they're near you,
you can whack them with a hammer,
with a backside to whatever side you're going to kill him.
I'm not trying to be polite.
I wouldn't use the claw if I was going to kill you with a hammer.
I just let you know right now I would only use the flat part cause it seems like
a gentlemanly thing.
How many,
how many of those do you think are people just trying to hit somebody over the
head with a hammer and knock them out?
Most of them like prompt them and then realizing as soon as you hit like,
oh,
Skillcrush most murders are murderers on purpose and I'm trying to kill you.
Half of them were done by Mc Hammer.
You think so?
Do you guys think you've ever kill somebody?
What could you under certain circumstances,
what do you don't think you could?
No,
I think I could.
Of course you could.
Yeah,
I could see.
I totally do.
It's been very pretty much proven that human beings can kill human beings under
the right circumstances.
It's not kill me.
Fuck Eddie.
Brian Bell to you should be able to,
if,
if it's,
if you have to,
I mean it's not something that you would want to do in life,
but say if you were with a girl and all of a sudden some guy attacked the girl,
it was kind of good as going to kill her.
Wouldn't you attack him and tried to kill him?
You would try to save your friend or would you run away like a little girl?
I just pissed all over your pants and scream and tried to call the cops and not
to intervene,
but could be.
It could be that how can happen if a guy was trying to beat your girl up and
you're absolutely sure you can kick his ass and you have the bat in your hand
and you're like club that go over the head with a bat,
right?
Yeah.
And if he died,
you would have killed him.
Yeah.
Right.
So you're very capable of killing a person.
Somebody.
Where can we have the greatest game of all though?
The real problem,
Ari killing people is that it's a power issue and the real power is,
it's not that like logically you shouldn't kill some people.
The only logical reason to kill people as the people that are doing something
really awful to the human race,
whether it's pedophilia or whether it's murder,
whether it's,
you know,
there's,
fill in the blank with whatever horrific crime against humanity.
Those people,
there's a very good argument for removing them from society.
But then the problem becomes like,
who gets to choose?
And that's what he killed his genital assays from.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you know,
people kill for a lot of kill for robberies.
The kill for a lot of reasons.
Yeah.
I knew a dude who killed a girl from,
uh,
killed a guy from money.
Do you think you killed somebody?
If they were just going to find out you were doing something and you were going
to buy them living,
you are going to have to go to jail for 20 years,
you know,
you probably shouldn't have done what the fuck we'll put you in jail.
I know.
Definitely shutting off,
but here we are.
It depends what kind of a person he is.
He looked,
he looked kinda like a little bit chubby.
Kind of looked like he had a snarky face.
Undercover cops kill him.
But your job tell him on the rocks,
like do anything wrong.
But he just looks like of you wouldn't like Surratt is around.
What does that,
what does that say?
I don't know.
Snitch.
Oh,
it was a Donnie Brasco fuck.
I don't remember.
Get their pages.
Snitches get their bitches.
No,
Brian,
he's just a gang of people
snitching and be like this when you're 55.
I'm really curious all that.
I uh,
you chose this life that shows when you're 55,
you could act like a 30 year old son.
We're going to move up to that quickly.
That was thinking about him.
His normal time live 17 years.
Yeah,
but if you looked at her all and did it in dog years,
about eight.
You really,
you just have a Martin low,
slow moving.
Progeria that's what you've got.
Just really slow at that.
Your body is withered away while you're inside.
Just still 14.
No,
he's 38 and it looks like he's 25 looks pretty young.
He's 38 years old.
Look at his face.
I was fairly young Logan.
I don't know people who look like he does.
He looks young.
He looks very good for,
for 25 years old.
Puffy,
puffy.
Yeah.
Slept on cat hair.
The kid got in shabby.
Be handsome with spark.
Got Good unique genes as far as keeping his face together.
Yeah.
It's not bad.
Look good with a beard,
but the reality is he's emotionally eight years old,
but it's works.
It works.
You know?
I mean like who's to say how you should live this life?
It's fucking,
I'll do it.
It's temporary.
Oreo.
Right.
Who are wondering totally down.
It's you start with you that we should start with you and examine,
examine your,
your behavior at the Tsa.
Oh yeah.
All right.
I heard that you won't take off your shoes now,
which is something that you'd never did with me.
I that I remember.
That's something new.
And think of it,
I've been set free by my association with other people.
What happens?
What are you doing?
Your association,
but not Brendan.
Uh,
Brent.
Why Bach?
He's such a Germaphobe.
He can't take off his shoes.
Right.
And I flew with him to San Francisco.
I was like,
how do you not do it?
Because I have a medical condition.
What's [inaudible] position?
He goes,
if they ask,
I just say something in Latin.
I just say a couple of Latin syllables and they say fine,
but they're not supposed to ask.
I was like,
and then you don't have to take his shoes off.
He goes,
no,
they just have to like swap it a little bit.
And then,
um,
and then uh,
he goes,
I like them patting me down to them.
I like the way it feels like a hug.
That's an important one box.
That creepy son of a bitch give me say that.
That's why he's doing it.
He might sit a little hug.
No,
no.
What do you want us to do?
He wants to complain and he gets Super Shitty with these people.
Yeah.
So he got super shitty with the one guy in,
in,
in La.
But that guy was pretty
easy going,
but then he got it
depends what they say.
I said,
I can't do it.
Medical condition.
Okay,
go this way.
Okay.
If they say,
are you opting out?
That was hard.
I don't know what that means.
When I say,
do you not want that or do you want to pat down?
And I go,
no,
I don't want to pat down,
but I'm not doing that thing.
So what are my options?
He's just trying to be Larry David.
No,
I'm just trying to not let them take away these freedoms from me without going
down with a little bit of a fight.
I see what they're doing.
They're just harassing us and I don't want to just let them do it.
They're not harassed.
We can hold out.
We can go back to what the fuck I was doing,
but what we'll do,
no,
let's go back to it all originates from this.
It originates from this,
this,
this opinion that you have that they're harassing you.
They're just bothering everyone.
It's just some giant bureaucracy.
Right.
But don't run efficiently in a lad.
A lot of issues with planes and terrorism.
I mean,
they really have theirs.
We're really wasn't an asshole.
Try to lay shoe on fire.
There was a there,
there really was a got through the CSA.
Yeah.
And the shoe bomber who got through Tsa.
That's why they started taking your shoes off.
They caught,
uh,
I don't know.
It's in the range of zero people caught anybody.
No,
they haven't.
They show all these weapons they've confiscated and stuff,
knives and such.
That's just,
I got one confiscated from me before.
They said,
well,
it's all I keep telling you,
forget about it.
That's what they confiscate.
Nobody,
they caught somebody on as much as I can.
They caught somebody recently that I remembered.
Uh,
that was like a whole plot to take down a plane and stuff like that.
Elegance probably stops them.
Yeah,
I think that's,
you're,
you're confusing the FBI and the CIA.
But CSA,
dia is Central Intelligence Agency.
That's just a large crooked organization mostly to deal with foreign shit.
Right.
And they just see AI is the Federal Bureau of Investigation.
Is that how it works?
I don't remember.
All right.
Don't you think?
Maybe just like,
Hey,
I'll just take off my shoes and walk through his machine and go like this and
that's cool.
I'm done.
And instead of having to deal with it and,
and just be an asshole to somebody that's just doing their job.
Absolutely.
Well,
hold on.
Let me back up on,
on,
uh,
let me get back to someone's just doing their job.
But yes,
it is.
It would be way easier just to kick off my shoes and go through it and be quiet.
But I saw it one day I was on a POC Cokie obviously,
and I was looking at them.
I like an hour to my plane took off and I was looking at them just stopping
everyone in.
Each and every person having to go through that scanner,
the old scanner,
we had to raise your hand and now again the new scanner,
you have to raise your hand.
It looks like they're conditioning us there.
Sorry,
who are they?
If they,
if they found the states government,
if they found a guy with his fucking shoe or the bomb packed and they shoe and
that guy could have been on an airplane.
If they don't check and on someone goes in with a bomb in a fucking shoe and
blows you out of the sky,
then what?
Yeah,
that's
current.
Do you not think that there's a deterrent for bringing a board bombs and bring a
board really dangerous shit on that could take down a plane like checking
people's bags
and you're not allowed to say you walk on that plane loads the Turner.
It's okay.
But that doesn't excuse that.
This is not the right way to do it.
Detroit.
Okay.
How do you think they should check your bag?
Um,
I think they should.
Yeah,
maybe.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Yeah,
but I will tell you this,
that I have read this.
Those things don't even check for those types of explosives.
The X rays.
Yes,
I do.
The X rays.
Yes,
they do x rays tests for plastic explosives.
[inaudible] got a very unique way it looks,
it looks like a big brick of clay and if you have c four,
if you have anything and it looks remotely like that,
they do a secondary check.
You know you for you to say maybe no reason.
No,
no.
There is a reason.
There's a deterrent.
I just don't think they're organized in any way.
And I don't like the word because there are people,
the check points,
this is with the 65,000 corrupt people,
corruptible people corruptible,
but they're also just people that are there for a job that exists because
there's a need and the need is to make sure that people don't go on planes with
fucking bombs because people are crazy ass holes and a lot of people are willing
to do something like that and blow themselves up and kill a bunch of people
because it's terrorism and become,
it scares the fuck out of people.
And because it has a lot of value politically,
obviously more throws a lot of value to blow people out of the sky.
You know,
you want to prove your point,
you know,
they will never end well then you have to be checked.
But I don't think we have to give up our civil liberties in order to stop.
Um,
what may happen,
Ari,
you're not giving it the able to delivery.
You're getting checked.
You're making sure that your,
yeah,
when they were able to do search for then and then they found out and did it.
And did some shit.
X Rays loosens people up.
There's a bunch of said,
okay,
we have to stop that now let's be a little bit more stringent.
Diplo,
the people who were in nine 11 and flew fucking planes into the towers,
Jack the,
they didn't blow it up,
but they hijack the planet.
Okay.
One of them blew up,
but they think that I was actually the United States government that blue,
that fucker from this guy flight 93 instead of went down.
Yeah,
we'll actually,
Rumsfeld said it was shot was Rumsfeld or one of them said it was,
I believe it was Roosevelt said it was shot from the sky and then corrects
himself.
Yeah.
Shot that fucking thing down.
They,
they,
they even had the eye witnesses who saw a military jet scrambling after that
plan.
Have you seen them fucking harass people in wheelchairs?
Yeah.
You know,
why are you seeing the of why are shit left and right?
They are just people and you get a wide variety with people.
You get competent people and you get income trained.
They're not trained well.
Well for them to be in charge of you.
I agree.
Get statement.
They make 50 50 an hour.
They're not true.
There's no training process.
Whether it's so small.
That's not like a cop.
We got to go through a whole,
I've researched it a little bit.
I agree.
Don't they don't have them.
They don't have like any firearm training.
There's nothing they do like a police officer does.
They don't.
They don't really know what the code is.
They never,
none of them agree at all.
Well,
you know why?
Because there's no people and here's why.
It's a giant bureaucracy and at this point that came out,
pare it down.
They cannot make it more efficient.
But a bunch of people that's working that's just running checkpoints on other
people.
Yeah,
but he,
that's his job if you don't like,
but they don't like it.
You don't attack the boys.
You do.
Here's why.
Just because someone's paying you to do something does not excuse that behavior.
Good or bad,
this case or another case,
but someone paying you to do something is not an excuse for behavior.
Whether no matter what it is,
I think we're dealing with some Holocaust share here.
Yes.
I mean you don't want to jump straight to that,
but let's just say it was something else.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It looks exactly like that.
Why are we raising our hands?
Why are we taking shit off?
Because they're checking you for bomber underwear.
Bombs again is trapping you for that.
That's what the fucking radar thing
for whatever it's called.
The X ray thing.
Ari.
That's why they're checking you better
when you're going through the screen about the x rays,
but they used to use and they sometimes use that use to use what?
X Rays.
The X rays.
The the box.
The same thing you're talking about.
Well those have more radiation.
No,
no,
but what?
What happened?
But they still use them.
Sometimes they started using this other thing because it's a visual imagery.
It works better.
You can actually see where the prominent issue is.
If someone's wearing a vest or something like that and the vast isn't metal and
you go through a metal detector.
Right.
Hold on.
What if the vest is in metal?
Look,
my watch doesn't go off in metal detectors.
Yeah.
Okay.
Looking at all it's metal go right through my weapon actors.
It's a battle,
a fucking bomb and a switch isn't a weapon either.
If you have a bomb and a switch on you likely it would be easier for you to go
through a metal detector that it would go through one of those scanner things.
When you're holding your hands up,
they could see if you have gum wrappers in your pocket.
Okay.
It's no joke.
Those,
those machines are incredible.
Yeah.
I had a dime and it told me,
he's like,
you have something to write pop.
I'm like,
no.
Oh yeah,
there's a little diamond there.
Yeah.
I had pills in my pocket pocket
once and they said,
uh,
what's in your pocket?
And I was like something and they said,
take it out.
I was like,
no,
what are you supposed to take it out?
So they know that you don't have anything that could blow.
I have pills in my pocket.
I can boner pills in my pocket.
I didn't feel like taking them out in front of everyone.
At the airport.
You know that giving up these,
yeah.
You know that's what you had in your pocket.
What if you had a stick of c four and what have you sat in fucking exit door and
blow your fucking brains out?
I punched a hole in the plan and they're not catching anyone doing those things.
I don't know that.
And I don't think you know that either.
They're not catching anyone doing those things.
Here's the deal.
The deal citing national security concerns and TSA will not point to any
specific cases in which a screener stopped a would be terrorist at a checkpoint.
You know,
they don't need that to check us for the liquids anymore.
You can just pretty much carry through.
Why did you do that?
Cause I think I there,
there,
there the techs are thing that the belt either recognizes it,
they have the technology to do that or they'd no longer think that's a
threatened anyway.
I don't think three years ago.
I think unless they're using some other equipment,
I don't know.
See how you could see what they can do it.
The old guy who ran the Tsa said that,
oh,
but because it's hard to,
the guy who used
to be the head of the TSA set it
and so he's going to completely discount what he said.
Well I didn't know what you're talking about.
You're the old guy who ran the TSA.
I thought you were talking about somebody you met.
Okay.
I didn't know you met the guy who ran the head of the CSI.
Sad that what three years ago.
What was the exact quote?
I don't have the exact quote in my head.
Well do,
what is the exact statement?
Is he saying that you can detect regular the thing when they send your bag
through they can just detect explosive liquids
or,
and the other one,
so you don't need that anymore.
It's a visual.
But he goes,
it's too,
too much work to change it.
So no one's bothered to change it because it's such a big corporation of 65,000
employees as army has,
um,
uh,
that they just won't change it.
Right.
Ah,
so again,
we just can't do stuff and they have the excuse.
I was like,
well,
if you don't like it,
don't fly.
Or You make some statement like,
well you know,
planes are flying out of the sky,
they're blowing up planes left to right.
You don't want planes being blown up to you.
So if you're in favor of any sort of like these guys are taking it too far,
then you're in favor of planes blowing up,
which is not the case.
Yeah.
But they actually have busted people.
It turns out they busted a guy named Kevin Brown,
a US army veteran who was uh,
trying to check luggage containing pipe bombs.
It's crazy.
Motherfucker had pipe bomb making materials and his luggage,
it was trying to put together a pipe bomb.
Yeah,
it was recent,
right?
Yeah,
he wasn't,
he was just trying to check it.
Yeah,
he was checking a pipe bomb.
I mean,
imagine if did,
they didn't have that security though.
And especially with all the recent school shootings and shit like that.
It seems like if they got rid of it,
we,
it would just open up.
You don't care for more on it.
Definitely go back to the old way.
And you definitely got to lock the cockpit door and tell him,
I'm waving in front of your own way.
What is the issue?
What issue?
What would we do in two thousand two thousand what'd we do there for security?
Well,
whatever they did,
it didn't work to the tech box cutters.
Yeah.
So we should figure out what they're doing now that's different and then figure
out if you really want to criticize it,
what it is is it's a
checking people for bombs and for things that are going to try to kill people on
a plane and take down a plane.
That's fine box cutters,
but they've proven over again.
You can get those on now.
We still got those wrong over and over again is through component,
but that's not the fault of the people that have arranged that.
I'm saying it doesn't really work for what would have happened.
What would have worked is locked the cockpit door.
Right.
Then that day.
Then they do that now.
Oh yeah.
That's a new thing they've learned.
Yeah.
For the most part,
that's probably [inaudible] nine 11 when they did it there.
So you agree that they have to check your bags to make sure you don't have
bombs.
They check something.
Okay,
so what do you have a problem with specifically that you get so riled up to
65,000 person army that has control over us.
That can tell you come with me.
Open up that let everyone look at you.
They can,
they can push
people that have no legs,
they can,
they can embarrass old ladies and we have to do what they say.
They can steal our belongings and we have to do what they say.
And there's just an untrained random dudes that are doing that,
that are making us raise our hand.
Like we're under arrest and I just don't like it.
I don't like it.
It's just gross.
The whole thing has growth.
No one likes it.
No one goes there and goes,
thank God these guys are doing their job.
We reacted under under a time of intense,
intense emotion where we didn't really have time to think it out and now we
already have all these things in place and we can't rethink what the TSA is.
Wasn't there checks before.
You'd have to check your luggage through a radar detector.
Yeah.
Or whatever it's called.
Not write about tech.
The X ray.
Yeah,
they've always checked it.
What specifically is the issue?
The pat downs,
the um,
they only pat dial if you opt out.
I don't get patted down.
I've never had a problem with anything.
I fly right through the security.
I'm in and out and gone.
It's like why even bother making that harder or more like,
especially if you had some weed on you or something ridiculous,
like why can't I mean fake weed but a fuck are you doing?
They just,
they're just a bunch of people you put up with like forties.
Yes.
But I think that's the issue.
Whenever you have people that are in any sort of position,
it becomes a job.
Whatever it is,
it needs to be done.
Say it needs to be you gotta you gotta Guard,
but the Guy Leans are coming in because there's a fucking,
this is your Barista at Starbucks with the aliens land.
You gotta be ready.
You got to have guys that are ready to guard it.
Well,
those guys are gonna fuck off their guys.
Normal people.
No matter what you do,
you're always going to have people that poorly implement whatever strategy you
have.
Their great the TSA,
you,
you're 100% I think they're great.
You're not a child.
You know what I'm saying?
So what do you think,
like why would you say that you think they're great?
I wouldn't say that.
I know you're watching,
forcing,
forcing your opinion by exaggerating mine.
No,
because I want you to tell me what you think the problems are with Tsa.
Okay.
The problems are with Tsa.
Say the same problems there are with any system where people get in any position
of power over people,
the obs automatically act like Douche bags to same as security guards.
I mean the same as bouncers at clubs.
It's the same as some cops.
And so is he difficult thing to have that kind of power over people and not
abuse it and not be cocky about it.
I remember when we got to the airport and there's this one guy who was being,
or just really attention to Horry attention ladies,
gentlemen,
please get your day.
It was like going through this big speech and [inaudible] and then,
well I would like one more request.
Everybody please smile.
I'm like,
you fucking Weirdo.
You just put us,
show you a fuck head.
It's like a street performer or something.
I mean it was like that's what it was doing.
Like he decided this is what he does cause everybody has to listen because he's
the man with the power,
the TSA guy.
But that's just one douchey guy.
I've met a million people that do it,
that are friendly is how he like how did you have a good time?
Yeah,
it was great.
Good.
Enjoy Chicago.
Chicago is awesome.
Boom,
you're in,
you're out.
Everything's fine when you're just interacting with some people that are doing
their job.
And I personally find I've never had a problem.
I've,
I've always,
they've always been pleasant to,
I've no one's ever got douchey
with me.
You know,
if I accidentally have my belt on,
I say I'm sorry and I take the belt off and I put it in the thing.
You know what I mean?
It's like your prostrate yourself for them,
Paul.
It's not prostrating.
It's just being nice to people while you're doing their gig.
Their Gig doesn't bother me.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't wanna I don't wanna I'm not flying with any bombs.
I'm not flying with any guns,
so I not worried about them checking my underwear.
Okay.
My,
my bag's pretty sample.
The Go.
Go ahead and look in there.
There's some toothbrush.
Toothpaste is no,
there's nothing to worry about,
you know,
so as long as there's nothing to worry about,
you sail right through.
Do I think that logic,
they could tap your phone if you're a law abiding,
no,
that it's not the same logic.
Jesus Christ your underwear.
Because tapping your phone and listen to intimate conversations.
Find out aspects of your life that you wouldn't want revealed or find out where
you live,
what you're doing,
what your plans are.
That's not the same thing as checking for them,
but under those circumstances sort of,
it's just that looking at intimate parts of your life and they can look,
looking at clothes.
I mean unless you got a bag of Dildos,
which by the way Stan hope did,
but if you're in the closet and you actually a purpose brought a bag of fucking,
after September 11th I had a whole suitcase filled with rubber fists and rubber
vaginas and Fis and decks and just everything and he just sent it through the x
ray so that if they had to like open it up and check it and it's like,
yeah,
that's my stuff.
Are you,
if you go to the Burbank and say turned to one of them on something like that.
So they had to find which one it was.
What I was saying.
Yeah.
If you go to the Burbank airport,
almost every single person that works there,
the staff of the people that check check you.
I've never had one problem.
Those are the most friendliest,
nicest ever just doing their job.
Aren't you scared from being such an Asshole,
I guess is what you would call it.
These people to get on some kind of no fly list,
especially since you're a comic and half of your job,
there's no fly list and here's where that fear comes from.
Them holding over you that if you cause too much trouble for us,
we're gonna threaten you to fear that you will no longer be allowed to fly.
That's a real thought,
but people have,
right?
You're not the first one.
Right.
And stop terrorism.
They are that to help them stop terrorism,
but be someone would put like someone like me or someone who mouths off too much
on a no fly list that would help us stop terrorism to make people live in fear,
but they might decide that you make things very uncomfortable and unpleasant for
a lot of people around you as well when you're at the airport because you were
yelling out that.
Do a lot of people just scared to say it on,
on,
on podcast too or anything like that,
just for the sake of put you on no fly list.
Yeah.
That's a real thought people have.
Oh,
they can just do this to you.
They can,
they can grab your ability to fly in the dark,
like a fucking gulag and just take you out of there.
All right.
My friend is so scared to fly that she has to take.
So drugs just
to calm her heart rate down just enough so she can even be there.
If you start like being intense to where she will freak out.
You know,
if you were to be intense around her,
she might go crazy.
That's when I was in intensive that Dennis will be the same thing.
Yeah.
She's on my responsibility.
But Frank's a big,
yeah,
but flying is a big deal for a lot of people.
I mean,
my mom's scared to fly.
I know a lot of people that are just doing that.
Bert Kreischer gets blackout drunk before he flies with blackout drunk.
She made him go to the movies.
Well,
some get fucked up.
he's also scared of balloons,
Joe.
Oh,
you gotta fucking balloon.
Jesus Christ.
Where's the booze?
Yeah.
Bird Christ is used to that shit.
And this is excused.
He's away from his wife and kids got no responsibilities going to get hammered
on a plane and there's nothing wrong with that bird.
Just fess up,
fess up with your anxiety ridden.
Here's the,
I don't mind taking the shoes off.
It's not that it's just there.
They're being there.
I don't like I,
you know what?
I think they're necessary.
I think at this point in our reality,
I wish they weren't necessary.
I wish I didn't have to believe,
and I'm not necessarily saying that it has to be run the way it's run.
I know.
I don't think it's efficient,
but I don't think that anything's efficient.
You know what else isn't deficient?
The DMV do you go to the DMV when you go to get your fucking license?
Just starts screaming.
I was for those who want a fucking car.
I don't want to Julie your bullshit.
It was a corrupt organization,
but I can get their license online.
I don't have to come in contact with them.
Can you really?
Yeah.
You can renew it online now.
Why not go in there and take a photo or anything.
That's beautiful.
Well,
you know there's a thing you could do at the TSA or you get preapproved and when
you get preapproved,
you don't even take your shoes off.
You just go right through because we fly a lot and they assume you wouldn't be.
No,
they do a check on you.
They do a check to make sure you're not some fucking psycho.
Yeah,
no,
not make sure he never got arrested at the airport for harassment with Tsa.
I thought you were going to get arrested.
Well,
Ari wouldn't be a rough yelling at them because you're yelling at people like
it's said illegal swearing.
Yes.
I'm calling them idiots.
Yeah.
He was calling the fucking idiots.
Why is that illegal Brody and going out though?
He did threaten to bring over the cops on me.
Well,
this is what I said,
that the TSA is trained authority over him.
He said,
I'll bring over metropolitan security officer or police officer.
That's what they do.
If I say the arrest you,
the other people arrest you.
What they're worried about is that you are being aggressive and they thought
that you could have been a crazy person.
[inaudible] they drove me crazy.
Right,
but the way you reacted to it,
it's like seven and ones a little scared violation.
No,
I'm not scared.
Don't you think that's a little weird that everyone's scared of being put on
this no fly zone.
I'm like,
that's a real thought.
Like don't piss them off or they'll put you on a no fly list.
Tsa and you should be worried about government corruption and anybody that puts
you in a government no fly list because you have espoused views that they,
you know,
they don't feel like fits the company line.
That's very scary.
Very scary and very dangerous,
but that's not what's going on here.
Well you need to worry company and put
on a no fly list.
It's just because of your behavior.
It's just you.
You made a scene.
I'm allowed to call him an idiot all I want.
It's not the way you're doing it,
your way.
You're doing it like you were like you,
you yelled and you escalated and you made it like a big deal.
So what are your problems with Tsa?
It's not good.
It's not efficient.
It's not this crazy long dumb lines.
It's a bunch of people running things like that guy with this stupid and one
more thing,
please smile.
That's very annoying.
It is annoying.
That's a person in a position of power.
And I think those same issues.
I think it's a problem with humanity.
When people get into positions of power,
they actually do feel like they have a,
you have to listen to them,
you know?
I mean,
I've had that with bosses.
I've had,
I mean we've all had that with teachers,
but people get in a position of power.
They act as if they have some,
an alien.
There's some indefensible authority over you,
you know,
they're just,
they're powerful and it's a natural thing.
They started,
well,
that's opportunistic people.
That's poor people also,
they were laughing and doing naked pictures of people.
They will laugh.
They were sitting in control and he's laughing.
I would too.
You went to,
they had that chance.
Humor.
I wouldn't have that big of job are you would probably come on those pictures.
I probably would.
I wouldn't be any better.
Don't get me wrong.
I wouldn't be better if I was in that job.
Right.
So I do the,
the fucking travelers as the enemy also.
I don't think it's that bad of a job.
I don't think it's that big of a deal.
I really don't harass,
harassing people.
That's your job.
It's harass people.
Because you have,
doesn't mean it's a real thing that no one has.
Obviously this.
Sometimes you have people doing anything in a position of power.
There's a certain percentage of wrong interactions are going to take place.
Where I'm putting untrained people in these positions of power of it.
Why was it would cost even more
taxpayer money to train these assholes and to pay him more money and to,
to to go and get more qualified,
more socially advanced people for the job.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
Where are you gonna get him?
You're getting people.
A lot of these people that work for the TSA,
there's not a lot of other jobs,
you know,
and that's what the issue is like they have to take this job.
It's not a bad job.
What do you want?
They can't get rid of the can't downsize it now they're unable to.
And is that what it is?
If it could be 5,000 employees,
it would make a tremendous dent.
You would see the mark on the on time or not necessarily
to downsize it.
They they,
they need to make it more efficient and it would be nice if people were more
pleasant,
hostile,
we privatized.
That's a,
that's an issue with human being.
Maybe prioritize it even if they privatized it,
man,
to be even creepier because then it would be some fucking giant corporation
instead of something that government,
that's what it was before.
Let's see what airlines would hire people.
Yeah.
I Dunno if that's good or bad.
I really don't know.
But what I do know is that you know your,
your anger about it,
it's going to get you in trouble.
Yeah.
You were people doing their email.
That's scary.
That's crazy.
You should not scream at anyone,
man.
He goes,
that's putting out bad.
Anyway,
I'm calling roll with my supervisor and the supervisor comes over.
He goes,
oh great.
the head idiot and this corrupt organization and he goes fuck
doing.
What do you want?
Like he's like talking to him like that.
Yeah.
What if he was,
I don't like them in a fan of yours.
That would have nothing to do with my feelings.
I thought your uh,
your comedy CD online.
It was really
punching nuns.
Cool.
Cause he said he was a fan of mine.
Doesn't have any awesome just doing my job.
I know,
but I've already told you I don't have,
I have a job above that.
You need to really care this much about it.
You need to fight the guy that's in charge of all,
it's not that they implied that.
They're just trying to tell everybody that the head of the TSA,
the guy who ran the TSA is the guy who owned the company that made those
scanners that we don't use anymore.
He was the one who said,
we need those scanners.
And then he sold to himself.
So the head of this company,
did you sure about that?
Yeah,
he was the former head went to this,
he got the contract opened up,
spent all this money that we use for two years and got rid of now the one that
was wasn't fully tested,
I guess he made billions and billions.
So much money.
How much is one of those things?
Costs,
how much?
I don't know how many dollars.
More than 70 bucks.
And they have them everywhere.
And the only reason we had,
and we didn't even invent,
we didn't invent this time that somebody who was like,
oh,
somebody tried to get through,
so we need this.
He just said,
yeah,
we need it now for no reason.
And now he has to be.
That's just from this
start,
TSA director,
Michael Chertoff.
Yeah,
that's his name.
Body scanning company.
So he's the former director.
So he left and started a business that makes these body scanners and then sold
them to the Tsa,
like the TSA,
how to buy his business.
So that sounds like some fuckery for sure.
Yeah.
So all this money's AV advocacy for the technology dates.
Back to his time in the Bush administration in 2005 homeland security ordered
the government's first batch of the scanners,
five from the California based rapid scan systems.
Today,
40 body scanners are in 19 airports.
Listen to this.
The TSA purchased 150 machines from them with $25 million in American recovery
and reinvestment act funds.
So in this summer when you know there's like,
Oh man,
we got to bring this economy back.
Number one,
they're throwing all that money back and vet the jobs they made.
They,
they threw $25 million at this cunt and his stupid fucking scanning machines.
If yeah,
if you had to choose between that going money,
going to that or men money going to mental health and you know,
education when he 5 million nutrition for schoolkids,
fuck you.
I just think you should find it on a larger scale than attacking poor employees
of Burbank airport or lax airport.
You know that when they're just trying to do their job.
I mean,
I already told you I don't respect that.
Just trying to do my job argument in any,
that's not
an excuse for it.
You're making it unpleasant,
but you're still going through it.
All you're doing is making an unpleasant,
yeah,
I would like to make it unpleasant for them.
I don't like with l let me ask you a question.
What if they would go further to get better testing,
even more tests.
They give me more clear about what you have in you.
Why would you want to go further?
Well,
they already did to get these scanners right,
but why would they have to go further than that?
It seems like we have to go that far because they didn't have scanners that
could see bombs.
Um,
I went to the,
if you were strapped
in response to anything,
drugs taped to your body or you're concealing something,
but wouldn't it be better like a plastic weapon strip search to be the best
thing?
Um,
my guests strip search would be the best thing.
Yeah,
but so why would we not go that far?
Like,
why are they,
I'm just,
it's sort of a slippery slope and I don't see why it's gone this far.
And I don't know why it wouldn't go even further.
Well,
the only way it would go even further as if something cataclysmic happened.
Yeah.
But the scanners,
there wasn't a result of anything happening or anything even trying to be ha to
happen.
No,
but it's just more efficient.
That's all it is more Joe,
you still go through those old machines with his watch on every time you'd like
to look at this and that crazy.
Now that doesn't happen.
Yeah.
And now they know they got new iPhones.
It,
it really is better technology.
I mean,
I,
I think I made a forum post on me that maybe I didn't.
Maybe I said I was Kinda,
and I decided that wasn't a strip search to be the best technology.
Yeah.
But we don't need that.
But they're not doing that argue.
It's like you're,
you're arguing against them escalating past the point where they're at right
now.
Well,
but,
but they escalated past the point where they were before and it wasn't based on
any need.
Joe Wasn't based on the need.
That old machine with this wash on,
you keep telling about his watch.
Who cares about his wife?
That wasn't a thing.
It's an efficient machine.
You can make like no good.
The texture watch,
that's fine.
If it doesn't detect a bomb or a knife,
that's not fine.
You would need to show me an example of that time.
They didn't detect the Obama nice seat plastic or guns.
Those radio things didn't see plastic knives that you have concealed and taped
to your body have plastic knives that are made of this composite plastic.
They can fucking kill you easy and they can see those now.
You can see those now.
There's a lot of shit that used to be in detectable if they can find,
you know,
I don't think that these things cannot detect,
but our eats nuts for you.
It's not a different experience.
You put your shit down.
I just talked like taking the power.
I just don't like they're making a step through these checkpoints.
I don't like that they have control and there's no say but yet you go through it
because you decide that what you're going to do is go through it and just annoy
people.
That's very childish though.
Well that's like a waste of energy.
Kind of like the seat on the airplane.
I don't even know what the suit in the airplane leaning back your seat on the
airplane when you're like yelling and kicking the back that Ari does that he
needs people see if they lean back on him and it's upset that you lean your seat
back.
You guys still still think that
it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I think it sucks that day habit so that people will use it.
There's like no space that everybody gets no science but it's already know space
and you're trusting dealt with the other side.
How much,
how much you should be able to lean back.
The reality is everybody has a seat and everybody sees it has a button and if he
does that you can do that too and everybody sort of accepts that.
You decide that you don't agree with it.
What if per seat went back?
What if a seat went back?
Even don't say that because it doesn't.
Okay.
Less far,
it doesn't matter.
Then you would have no reason to argue about,
here's what I'm saying.
You are trusting Delta or American or United to tell you as a person how,
how much room you could take away from the person behind you.
You're not taking away that person's room.
Everyone's sharing space.
Arm Chair goes like this and the person
and their chair goes like that.
Also,
you've just shared space in a different way.
You're not taking away anything.
Sandwich the emergency.
Okay,
so you know why I'm British.
See I just to get that little extra space for their legs and back.
It's not like you have to move,
have you not?
So that means
exit row that that person doesn't annoy potential authors should fairs.
That's why you don't find pictures.
I seen a picture of crumpled up with a guy.
Can't even use this computer because the person in front of them lean backwards.
All right?
And you know what?
That's why you go to,
you wouldn't think that'd be a cool thing to do,
to not lean back and take it.
You nailed it.
If you lean back when that guy's doing that,
that you would no longer have that issue.
It's not,
that's not it.
That's not real.
That's,
that doesn't make up for it.
That's you're wrong.
It doesn't make up for that doesn't add the same amount of space to you.
You still can't see.
Then when they're back here,
I've already looked.
Yeah,
so it's a purely a laptop issue,
is that what you're saying?
Just all sorts of just comfort issue.
If you want to look at this
green or in front of you and the guy leaves back,
you're like,
ugh.
You know,
it's annoying when people lean back and forth,
you,
everyone gets annoyed by that.
Everyone does,
but that doesn't mean he should kick the back of their make their whole day.
Horrible because honestly it's Brian.
The last time I did it was five years ago.
Okay.
Do you get annoyed every time people do it?
Every time people lean back and take away that space?
Yes.
I get annoyed but I don't kick.
Do you know that that's ridiculous though that everybody has a seat.
Everybody's seed has a button and everybody used that button and no one ever
ever says,
oh my God,
I can't believe this person in front of me is reclining their chair.
What?
No one ever says that.
No,
you didn't see that Twitter responses after the last time we talked about this.
What hundreds of people tagging us both saying,
yeah,
that Shit pisses me off.
Pisses me off.
When people leave bad poor cons to it might suck,
but like I like when somebody leans back and I'm on my laptop,
I'm like,
yeah,
that's his chair,
but he wants to lead his chair back.
I don't always lean my chair back,
but as a woman too,
I want to be able to see that you are inflicting some sort of pain on another
human and say,
I'm not going to do this right.
Melodramatic fuck pain on someone by reclining your chair.
You are taking away the small amount of comfort they have on an too small
flight.
We've been over this.
You've agree is all I have is already too small on this.
It's already too small amount of space.
Don't say that.
I agreed on this.
We have been over this and you have agreed that it's already period.
Yes.
It's almost not enough to take some more of that away.
You don't see you.
How can you not see that?
That would be hard for somebody.
Ari,
there's a huge difference between how could you not see that it's better if the
guy doesn't recline and going,
that's his CD wants to recline.
He wants to recline because he's more comfortable when he's sitting back.
I don't mind.
I don't really give a fuck Ari.
It doesn't bother me that much,
but I certainly don't think that I should be able to kick his fucking
I.
That's just five years ago.
I did it three times ever.
I'm just saying I got annoyed by that stuff.
Got Annoyed to the point with a reason why we talked about it in the first place
because I hate it because I hate,
I hate it's going to start kicking.
You know?
They make a device that will stop people from leaning back.
Now you can attach it to their chairs.
You can attach it to your your tray and so people can no longer lean back.
It's like a break,
so that day Pete bill in front of you,
you can't lean back their marketing,
their marketing of that purely because of Ellen's apparently it is.
It's only because of the con,
their marketing and selling a device side one of those.
You're a cunt.
Yeah.
If you buy one of those things and it's stops the guy in front of you from a
client whose seat,
I say you're a cunt.
That's a country thinking dude.
Do have you thought picture of that guy like,
yeah,
that's not real art.
There's no that.
That's like a parody.
It's pretty close.
All right,
awesome.
When I see my computer screen closed as they fucking Shane back,
come on.
You then just don't use your computer.
Awesome.
No dog.
Certain airlines that have more room than others.
You also know that more.
There are certain airlines that have more room than others,
like I think it's American or something like that.
When you lean back,
there's room actually where the,
that's the most room and then there's like Delta where it's like you're almost
about to die.
Question about it.
They are giving you too little space.
Yeah,
no question about it,
but I don't think that's the fault of someone who's hitting the recline button
on an open chair.
Yeah.
It's not his fault that they give it to little [inaudible] little straight hair.
I don't have any problem with it,
but for the sake of leaning right
back.
Yeah.
I had no problem for some people it makes them more comfortable.
I,
yeah,
it's like a blanket of human on you.
Especially with the girls high and you have a girl kind of laying on your,
I don't think that ever happens all of a sudden Bryson fucking penthouse
letters.
You just making shit up.
You're fuck,
are you doing?
Yeah,
I can't.
I mean that's what business classes for two because that's,
you're supposed to have more room because you have a laptop and you're actually
doing business where most people like myself,
at least I lay back,
I sleep the whole entire flight or something like that,
you know?
So you're doing business.
You're a taller person.
You might want to pay the extra $20 zero videos on my computer.
It's one 20 bucks and it's way more than 20 bucks.
It depends a lot on reason at all.
Do you still have an iPad son when those little seven inch ones?
Yeah.
Look
at this.
Read this bitch.
Cute little baby.
Cute.
So easy to use.
Look at that.
Aren't you?
Buy them all over the mushroom soon.
Oh we need to do much of it.
Cause you're kicking people and yell at people at the airports.
Jesus Christ.
Not projective.
That is,
I don't think we need to do mushrooms.
Why do we need to do mushrooms?
All right,
please explain.
Because I don't think it would be that,
that,
that rude to another human it once if you do them right.
Oh my God.
I think you a first class.
Okay.
No I don't.
I don't either.
I don't recline on people.
Okay.
And by the way,
if I did recline at people,
I don't think it'd be that big of a deal.
You don't,
there's no zero plenty of spots.
But I pay for that space because I don't like the issues I do.
I do agree that coach tickets suck a fat Dick.
They're there,
they're fucking spaces too small.
So I go out of my way and pay extra money and I understand that other people
can't afford that.
Some people don't lean back on.
So most of my life I did do that and most of life I did fly coach and when I
flood coach I would recline if I wanted to clear the people in front of me.
And you said it a thousand times,
believe
Jesus fucking Christ.
You think that we need to do mushrooms because we don't agree with you and
you're hyper aggressive way of kicking.
I think it's,
I think it's a,
that was pretty much him kicking people's chairs.
But I think this is why you needed a bunch of us because it helps you find an
empathy with other people.
I see the empathy,
I,
but I also see that you're,
you get real aggro about shit that can be avoided and I think that if someone
leans their chair back and I'm sitting in coach and the thing is like this and I
can't do it anymore,
I will fucking close it and I'll pick up a book or I'll do nothing.
I'm not going to get upset at some guy who's just using his chair function.
It's not that big of a deal.
You saying that I need to do mushrooms because I don't see the empathy and
you're going Berserk over something you're not going to ever control is
ridiculous.
The TSA agent,
Ari,
you're not screaming at this guy.
I don't like their jobs at all.
Yeah,
well you're not looking at them as seen the most aggravated like I in my life,
pretty much the TSA people.
He's being really hypocritical on that.
That's it,
rob,
kind of.
So you're saying that you don't,
we don't have empathy for you getting upset because you can't use your laptop
and these people just have a job that you don't necessarily like and they're not
necessarily being shitty to you at all.
That I saw the way those people reacting to you and you were yelling at them.
No,
no,
no.
Stop.
Just not the individuals.
I went over this with Brendan Walsh wants,
then he was like,
he made it kind of clear to me.
It was like they just them saying,
you have a job.
It's not a reason to do anything.
Obviously you could take it back to Holocaust Times.
You went over it with Brendan Walsh.
So what we're saying makes no sense.
No,
no.
He just sort of made it clear to me.
It was like,
I was like,
well,
come on man.
They're just doing their jobs.
The same sort of thing.
But I just,
I just sort of became clear trend in Washington.
Another guy looks for problems.
I,
I don't,
I don't agree.
I think that these people are just doing their job.
I know,
but that they would ask their job is hard didn't if they were actually being
shitty to you.
Yes.
But we're not being shitty.
It's not that,
it's not that it's,
I think they work for this organization that just is bad for us.
We don't like it.
Okay.
But while you're there and you are interacting with them,
you're choosing to make things difficult.
It's not a difficult experience.
You're creating a difficult experience out of an experience that's not difficult
because you have a problem with the fact that they exist.
Yeah.
But yet,
you know they exist and yet you know you're going to interact with them.
So you're choosing what you're saying.
And I tried this once,
I tried to,
like the first time I saw it and I looked at what they were and I was like,
oh,
they're just,
people make us go through checkpoints.
I think I thought this over and I was like,
it's even worth,
you know,
having a problem with that.
Is it even worth like,
you know,
getting upset at all about it.
But man,
it just sort of just bothers me.
I know why you need to do mushrooms.
You fuckhead.
Yeah,
I will.
So silver,
difficult.
Awesome.
This is such a ridiculous stance to take because you're a professional comedian,
you fly all the time and it's just an experience.
It's not bad.
The idea behind it behind Andy,
loss of civil liberties and bedtime time,
any loss of privacy.
I don't,
I'm not a fan of any of that shit,
but that's what this is a part of flying.
It's not a major issue in my opinion.
And when I see these aberrations that people like to point out examples of
things that Tsa has done,
like someone stole something,
I absolutely think that can happen.
I absolutely think that people can fuck up people.
Can you hire the wrong person?
People can sneak through the net and be assholes.
But in my experience with the TSA,
they're just people.
They're just regular people and this is what they do.
And I do a whole organization,
I say hi and they say hi back.
I say,
how you doing?
Everything's good man.
How you doing?
And it seems like really easy.
I see a bunch of people that are just working and you know,
they're trying to do their job when there's fucking thousands of people going
through there every day and it's trying to keep chaos and everything orderly.
It's gotta be really fucking difficult.
What do you think everyone's problem is with them?
They suck.
That's during you through it.
I always said that the papers to people that work at the TSA are often the same
people that work in the fast food counters.
They just switch roles.
You know,
like the ones at the airport,
he used to work for Burger King.
Now your bomb scanning.
How that I'm up.
You know,
they're just,
they're just people with jobs,
man.
You know,
I don't want that job.
I'd wish that job wasn't necessarily,
but it seems to be necessary and someone needs to do it.
So who the fuck is going to do it?
Well,
unless they're paying people 50 bucks an hour,
you're not going to get people that are,
you know,
that have a lot of other options.
So they don't have that many options.
So who are these people?
These are people that are impoverished.
They don't live in the best neighborhoods,
they don't have a lot of opportunities,
whatever it is.
And so those are the people that they're trying to get to be professional.
Those are the people that are trying to get to represent their company.
And of course it doesn't run smoothly.
Like most human beings.
You put them in a bunch of,
you'd put them in a situation,
any situation,
and have a group of them that are in control over a massive group of people and
you ask them to behave orderly.
Good luck with that.
But my point is that when you go to the airport,
you know that there are going to be Tsa agents,
you know the whole procedure.
That's what are alike.
But there are going to be though.
But this,
I've had one of the guys say
like,
I was like,
why don't we take our shoes off?
And he was like,
you got it.
I'm like,
why don't we take her shoes?
And I was being moved me Jim,
same way.
But,
um,
does the answer at the end was if you don't like it,
don't fly.
And I was like,
that doesn't seem like a good enough reason.
He doesn't represent the companies.
Just a dude.
He's just working your some dickhead who doesn't want to take your shoes off?
He's like,
I have to tell you to take your shoes off.
That's my job.
My job is when you go through here,
I have to make sure he shoes don't have bombs on him.
Please take your shoes off.
Why do I have to go shoes off?
You're like,
Oh God.
He's like,
cause you have to,
why should I say,
yeah,
you should be able to see it from his point of view,
your,
your lack of empathy for them is a very hypocritical when you want people to be
empathetic black.
Well yeah.
Obviously I'm totally,
definitely not on exact point from my whole life,
but this is a,
an unnecessary,
yeah,
I thought about that and I don't know,
it's,
this is all new stuff for me.
I'm trying to figure it out,
but I don't like that the fact that the TSA is,
they're taking away our civil liberties and I don't,
I hate even saying the word civil liberties because it because it makes it seem
like you're a really blurry about civil liberties.
The TSA is not a concern with you should be focusing your efforts on the
national defense,
the Patriot Act.
You should be focusing your,
your your,
but this is the one I sent.
This is when I come in combination from the Obama Administration that they've,
they've protocol to use drones,
armed drones on u s civilians and they're trying to figure out how,
how to get away with that.
Like drones with guns like to shoot you out of the fucking sky like that,
that if you want to worry about civil liberties,
I'm with you,
but this is not one in my opinion,
it needs the kind of attention that you're not doing it.
Maybe it's just that I'm not used to it yet or something.
Once I've seen it,
you're choosing to get upset.
You're not being upset because someone is forcing you into a position where you
have to angrily react to stop them from doing it.
You're choosing to turn this into an aggressive moment and it's not necessarily,
absolutely.
I was choosing to,
yeah,
but it's not necessary and I don't think even I avoid it doesn't accomplish
anything and makes us angry to accomplish it.
But what it is is childish.
It's not necessary.
It's childish and it's negative and you you fuck up the day or the,
at least the experience and depending on how people are.
Yeah,
that was definitely the intent.
That's definitely a 10.
I understand,
but you shouldn't,
it's not necessary.
I would run into those same people.
You know what I'm say hi.
What's up?
How you doing?
And Brian would run into a saint.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah obviously.
But we both get to the same goal and one of us avoided or we all,
Brian and I avoided any conflict.
Whereas you went through this stressful situation.
If I yell at someone,
okay,
if I get to the point of yelling at someone,
it's because I want to kill you.
Okay.
Cause you,
you've done something that's either horrible or you're dangerous or you're
threatening my health and I'm in a situation where I'm letting you know,
like I'm yelling too.
This shit could get crazy right now that you're not getting crazy at the
airport,
you're yelling because you know they're not going to yell back.
You're yelling because you know that they're forced to act in this very
politically correct.
And that's bullying.
Yeah,
because you're,
you're putting them in a position where they can't react to you the way you're
reacting to them go or your fucking head idiot at this fucking corrupt
organization.
But they can't talk to you like that.
Me through this.
Okay.
Because aren't they also,
I'm not trying to be right here,
but aren't they also putting us in a position of having to fucking just every
single time we go having to like give up a little something,
feel a little bad.
Well not the one where they hesitant check your shit,
but I don't feel bad.
I'm telling you when I go through it,
I don't feel bad.
I,
it doesn't bother is a way for him.
I don't have to put my trays away.
I could leave him there and I know that they would put them.
I tried to help them out of a nice thing to do.
I've gone off there almost every UFC when I go to the airport,
I talked to some dude who's a UFC fan who works there and we always have
conversations.
Holy Shit Man.
But that one was crazy.
Like what do you think's next for George Saint Pierre?
You know?
I mean obviously that's me and I'm in a different situation.
That was nice then,
but once I saw that it was like,
this is sort of like,
it's too much what they're doing.
Okay.
And once I saw that that I had more,
I had a lot more trouble with it.
Now I don't know what naked scanner,
the naked scanner scanner.
Just the stop your checkpoints on Hbo.
You pulled your cock out on Hbo and you worried about that.
You can go look at my Dick while you're still worried about not worrying at me.
It's not that I'm worried about them taking the control to be able to laugh at
me.
It's just a job,
man.
It's a,
I don't know what I'm saying is as the group that the transportation security
administration,
them taking that,
taking that power.
So it's just because of the naked scanning.
Then that was sort of all of it.
You know,
that they have to look at bags to make sure that people don't have explosives.
the people are crazy fucks.
You know when we were in Vegas,
do you know this weekend when we worked at Mandalay Bay,
which was by the way,
fucking awesome,
great time.
When we worked at that venue,
they had to go through metal detectors.
Who did the people,
the people that came to that show.
Yeah.
When you go to Mandalay Bay,
you go through metal detectors.
It's not cause Vegas wants to take away your civil liberties.
Okay.
It's cause he didn't want anybody to get hurt.
They want to make sure that,
you know,
maybe we should grab knives with.
Maybe it's a fucking Ted Nugent concert.
Do you want to bring their own bows and arrows?
He can't.
Vegas of,
okay.
Hey,
what are you doing with arrows?
Oh Man,
I don't even know.
I think it's just because of the lines that here's what I think in large groups
of humans that makes me mad or I'm,
yeah,
I think,
I think it's very stupid if I me and you fly almost every week that we have to
wait in the same line as this woman that's never flown out.
When you're doing well you don't in a way.
But at TSA appreciate it.
You could do that.
I never really go.
Yeah,
I'm saying that you can do that.
No I can't.
Why not?
Try it.
You can know.
What do you mean?
It's not everybody.
Did you try to sign up online?
Uh Huh.
What'd they say?
They won't accept you client.
Really?
It's not everybody.
It's not like I'm a flyer.
I can just get checked waiting on it.
That's just what people,
no,
no.
Almost everybody I know that works for the UFC goes that.
What did they decline you on?
What do you mean when they,
when you ask say pre,
so what you're saying is you went through the security,
the pre security screening thing online.
It's Tsa for lady told me to do it.
So you gave in your information and they just decided to decline you?
Yeah.
When did this happen?
Three months ago.
When was I in DC.
Okay.
It was a,
it was uh,
it was at the DC airport.
Okay.
Do you have a record in any way?
No.
I went online and tried to do it and it's like you can't do,
you can't get it.
But yes,
Tsa pre,
but it did it like ski.
Do you give them your social security number or something?
All that stuff.
And then they,
they did a background check on you,
I guess.
Yeah.
I don't really know how it is.
Amazing Racist Shit.
Probably some,
someone saw that and like this motherfucker thinks he's funny.
It's probably make it fun.
So what do you think it is?
Why?
Why do you think I have the hatred there?
Think you're a smart guy and you see a logical shit,
but what I think is that you're not,
you're,
you're not being empathetic and you're creating an employee unnecessary anger.
You're creating unnecessary anger.
You're creating for the,
for you,
for them.
For everybody.
For me,
it's not so bad.
Generally,
you were there,
so we kept talking about it,
but generally I do it.
I forced myself to fuck with them and then I just go back to being high and,
and how much time you didn't take your day,
do you?
Do you smell all of it?
Like no,
no.
Seriously,
like
online right now.
[inaudible] dot com slash always Shaffir poster along with it.
I just think it's,
it's,
it's unnecessary.
It's,
yeah,
yeah.
If you're going,
I thought about this too.
It's like I'm only Raleigh myself up,
and even that stuff about the NDA or whatever else that is,
it's like what do we have the power to stop any of these things?
But you have to do with the power of the con,
contact your congressman,
you have the power to write letters to senators.
You have the power to make petitions online.
You have the power to talk about it in social media.
So they understand that people are very upset about these trends and they
understand that when voting comes around again,
they're not going to vote for people that represent these trends.
You know?
That's why so many people were excited about Ron Paul.
Yeah.
That's why so many people,
I think Obama sort of represents the same representative.
Same thing too,
but if he's going to be the one that,
fuck no,
he doesn't represent that he was representing it.
No.
Was representing it.
I mean,
I mean he was like,
for the first term he was portraying that thing.
He was representing someone who would be Justin for the people.
Well,
he said a lot of things that were just not accurate at all.
Like about closing Guantanamo Bay and about changing the way we do business.
I think once he got in there,
he realized he was dealing with a machine.
It's way more fucking crop.
What I'm talking about is a guy like Ron Paul who really,
absolutely 100% set.
And if you know,
if you,
did he say a ball buster?
Tsa.
Well,
he thinks that you should abolish the fucking Federal Reserve.
He thinks you should.
Oh yeah.
He thinks she should get rid of like a lot of major government organizations.
He thinks they're ineffective and he thinks that they're criminal.
Well,
you know,
the fucking
Kennedy wanted to get rid of the CIA,
but the thing is those things will just keep them if they're corporations,
which they are each like branch has said,
so incorporation.
Yeah.
Um,
they really,
they,
they fight to stay alive.
The corporation will fight to stay alive,
which is like the DEA getting organization necessarily,
which is why the dei keeps posting medical marijuana.
I went,
it's been proven over and over again.
The marijuana is just not dangerous,
but the reason why they're going in and busting it because it's written down on
paper somewhere and because if they don't do it,
then how do they justify the fact that they have x amount of agents?
If all of a sudden 50% of their busts,
if,
let's just say 50% of all the Da's buster marijuana bus,
I don't know if that's true,
but let's say that all of a sudden now there's 50% less work mean it's 50% less
agents,
50% less offices,
and it's lots of federal government.
If you don't need congress,
let's say you don't even need congress right now,
which is how the whole transition from prohibition to prohibition against
marijuana,
so it was so seamless,
it's just keeping swipe a year and a half,
two years,
the same people,
they just filtered them from one to the other.
Yeah.
Cunts.
It's people.
It's,
and I think the real problem is that we,
it's an,
there's an ineffective method of communication that we've been operating under
for the longest time and that method is writing things down on paper and then
that becomes a frozen doctrine.
Okay.
That's one issue.
And then there's the other issue where other people are allowed to come along
and altered that doctrine because they were elected officials like presidents
when they do executive orders and things along those lines.
And it becomes like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You are just,
you're making these decisions without consulting the will of the people that are
absolutely fundamentally altering the rights and liberties of the people that
elected you into a position of power in the first place.
You're essentially removing their power once they've given you power.
Yeah.
That's the reason we don't trust them.
We don't trust,
we don't trust them,
the people anymore.
They're going to fuck straight up.
So we'll take the power away.
And so for them,
according to the founding fathers,
that's treasonous.
That's treasonous.
It's absolutely everything that's against the concept of being American.
But like anything else,
once you're,
once you've established an organization,
if fight to stay alive and government is fighting to stay alive,
[inaudible] positioning itself more and more complicated and intertwined with
our lives because the reality is when we have more access to each other the way
we have now with the Internet,
you know,
the way we have now with podcasting,
we have an ability to explain things and communicate with people in a way that's
never existed before.
So you don't rely on daddy anymore as much.
You don't rely on daddy government to let you know what the news,
our daddy government doesn't have to tell you what the news is.
Daddy,
daddy government.
You know what I mean?
You can go on Twitter and you find out what's going on in Congress.
The reason we got Congress,
cause if you're live in Tennessee,
you can't go to Washington,
make your voice heard.
So we'd all get together all as Tennesseans and say,
Hey Bob,
you go,
you'll be our congressman.
Right.
You know why they did it?
Why?
Because people had horses.
Yeah.
But now email,
now we have email.
So we don't even need,
we don't need that job.
The reason we have that job,
US congressmen,
yeah,
there's no longer necessary.
Well they won't let that job go away.
Don't think that's necessarily the case.
I think some of them evolved since the leaves in,
you know,
the constitution and you know,
they can be effective as a politician.
I don't think it's necessary to get rid of Congress,
but I think that like everything else it's like,
it's really hard to find really good people that can think and that are smart
and motivated and are doing it for the right reasons.
Like why do most people want to be senators?
Why don't most people want to be congressman?
Why wants to be,
want to be mayors?
Are they really looking out for themselves or they looking out for the people?
Are they really these amazing,
amazing humanitarians that are just trying to elevate their community?
I say very few are,
I say a lot of them are just people like the Tsa because it's doing a job.
Yeah.
Cause when we were kids we looked at all the politicians like these,
these like Uber Noble people.
Cause there are a few offer.
A few are.
It's almost like ideally it is,
but really it's just some guy we would like though,
like in a movie the president has always like Super Noble,
you know?
And it was,
we would love to go down with the ship.
Yeah,
we would love that.
But we all know it's really hard to find super noble people,
period.
You know,
why do we keep,
I mean,
I tried to be the nicest.
It's sort of become disillusioned.
I'm not a super noble person.
I mean,
I guess I might be if you compare me to a lot of Douche bags,
but I,
you know,
I'm a guy who regularly breaks marijuana laws federally.
Don't anymore.
Just quit,
quit a couple of days.
But you know what I mean?
I mean,
I,
uh,
I occasionally will drive above the speed limit.
I,
but I don't,
I mean,
I called people [inaudible] on an Internet show.
I don't think I do anything necessarily bad,
but I wouldn't want,
I wouldn't,
but what I'm saying is I wouldn't want me as a fucking president,
you know,
it's like to get a person to a position where you think they would be the right
person.
You want a Yoda,
you'd hook up,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
you want to,
why master?
And we're not in it for good.
We're not dealing with wise masters.
We're not dealing with people that have spent their time doing yoga.
And Meditating and contemplating the the best possible potential future of our
culture where we're dealing with idiots.
I mean,
he left Mitt Romney almost got into fucking office,
a guy in a cult,
an active guy in a cult who made a career at a fucking over corporations and
fucking over people and essentially hijacking a system and making millions and
millions of dollars.
He's a total twat bag.
He was 43% president.
He was almost there.
I think it was more than 403 7%.
It was pretty close.
Close enough.
So it's shocking.
Fuck.
I mean when I drove for unknown,
the Mormon,
I drove from
La to San Francisco during the whole election thing was like right,
right when it was going down.
Oh my God.
It was a wreck in a railroad track.
Everywhere you look,
there were these fucking Romney posters.
When you get to farm land,
all those dumb fucks.
This is funny thing about those,
those farmer folks,
like not saying that all farmers are dumb fucks,
but a lot of them are dumb fucks and a lot of them,
like they just all,
they'd go straight conservative right away.
Conservative like automatic knee jerk conservativism like the perfect kind of
like dumbo secure conservativism whether just dumb just dummies,
just they're not doing it because they sought things through.
They're doing,
it goes,
oh,
these barker and the hippies and that was everywhere you go,
there's just giant Mitt Romney poster.
So I'm like,
well,
you're saying is you're looking at a guy who's in an organization that was
created by a con man who was 14 years old who created a fake religion that's
based on 100% bullshit you like,
it's just tough because people are born with it to then I was like,
they can't fight it anymore.
Oh,
he wasn't just born with it.
He was born with it from a fucking dad who lived in Mexico.
His Dad was born in Mexico,
one in Mexico.
Do you know about all that?
I didn't know they went,
oh dude,
he's such a,
he's not just a regular Mormon.
You don't understand who Mitt Romney is.
Mitt Romney was a part of a Mormon sec that left America because they wanted a
fuck multiple wives.
So they moved to Mexico and the 1800 [inaudible] away with it.
Yeah.
So the Romney family still has a massive fucking ranch in,
in Mexico.
Yeah.
And there's not just one Mormon family down there.
There's a bunch.
Was that the ranch?
It was called the,
and Bob.
Who had that?
Who at that ranch?
It was called the,
did you say n bomb?
You just sit embalm.
I don't know.
I figured there'd been enough gas as he's backing.
So passive aggressive.
Um,
I don't think,
I don't know if it's them.
I don't think it is,
but there's more than one gigantic Mormon family down there.
And in fact they've had like shootouts with the cartels.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you know,
they don't want the cartels around the cartels have kidnapped them and killed
some of them and you know,
they,
their arm to the fucking teeth down there.
It's crazy.
Like when they moved there in the 18 hundreds there was really virtually very
little difference between America and Mexico.
I mean there was differences,
but right across the,
yeah,
because it wasn't enough to warrant,
you know,
staying in America and having one wife,
they're like,
what?
How does it go there?
Fucking crazy.
And you get all the same TV shows they do,
which is none.
But if you had like nine wives,
you got to cut your eight wives loose.
You're like,
oh,
I got to pick up money bitches.
And you know,
if you pick one,
you're like,
God damn,
I picked the wrong one.
You know,
you'd always ever Gretz a year.
And she's like,
I don't want to blow you anymore.
What?
Ah,
but Margaret and you start sending pigeon letters to those eight women
that you cut loose cause back then,
you know,
you can't even fucking calm and say,
oh you don't.
Oh yeah.
Let me make phone calls real quick.
Let me see if
I can even make it out.
It's still alive.
Yeah,
you could get those a lot to Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee.
You could send Morse code,
they add,
um,
teletype or
telegraph.
They had,
um,
Morse code was,
that's like military though.
But when they would send messages,
remember like those old west movies are like Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee will get the
wires coming in today.
Do,
did he do like someone could send a message to say it's a larger goal.
You just need to think it through instead of just reacting.
Just like there was something distasteful to her when I saw that they was just
just tasteful.
Well,
it certainly can be.
And if you run into someone who really is being a cunt,
that's just a human issue.
If you run into some guy,
I mean,
I've seen,
there was one time I saw this dude,
oh,
I know what they were.
They were um,
telling this lady that she had to get out of her wheelchair and uh,
she had to go through a scanner and this lady was really busted,
showed up.
She was really old and busted up and uh,
it was sad.
I'm just like,
come on man,
this is ridiculous.
You should be able to wheel that wheelchair in,
scan it,
make sure there's nothing in and that lady should be able to stay in her fucking
wheelchair.
90 fucking years old.
I know what it was now,
but the liquids that they can have up at slower process and so they can have
people elected to could go through there so they can take that perfume,
whatever or snow globe,
whatever they bought,
they can go there but it would be slower and to take more work for them.
It's to that line.
But they said no.
Well yeah,
that sounds like a pain that Dick.
I'm like,
no,
I want to wait for my flight to bleed delayed because you've got some Chanel
number five that Brad Pitt's pushing.
Well they won't delay a flight for you.
I know that.
That's,
that sounds.
That sounds annoying.
Yeah,
that sounds like it would slow the process down.
Yeah.
You have to be like one line of the site and all that.
You go there,
they go there voluntarily.
I think the real problem,
why is or is going to be guys who want to blow up plants and I don't want them
to be able to go on with fucking,
you know,
a big flask of explosives strapped to their back that no one saw when they were
coming to the radar detector waited.
Um,
I wouldn't have been planes became as the most important thing.
Well they thought about blowing up planes.
United States was using that and operation Northwoods is a part of a false flag
event.
They were going to blow up planes and they were going to blame it on the Cubans.
It's one of the things that people are scared of the most.
They're scared of plane flight,
they're scared of crashing.
So one of the best ways to instill terror in people is to add the fear of death,
which everybody already has and then add it to a fear of flying.
That's why they don't scratch it like a,
like a super bowl or anything like that.
Why hasn't that happened?
Think about that.
Think about,
I mean,
if you really had like a,
a nuke bomb or something like that and you really had something that you really
want to scare the fuck out of people and you know there's going to be 80,000
people in this town and there were all gonna come down to watch this one game,
why wouldn't you drop it on?
I think I started with radar
detective metal detectors for um,
malls.
They probably should.
Yeah.
So every time somebody walks in and you should have maybe,
yeah,
I mean it was it a movie theaters,
theaters here.
They should do that in the bad neighborhoods.
You know,
and I'm not saying that people who have been approved for concealed carry
permits and you know,
security specialist and the like,
it shouldn't be allowed to carry.
I think they should be allowed to carry,
I don't have a problem with people having guns.
I have a problem with crazy Pete with people unlicensed people that aren't going
to have a problem show your license.
I think we have a real issue with people not reporting and dealing with people
who have serious mental issues.
To almost every one of these people that have done something really fucked up.
A lot of people saw it coming.
Almost everyone in the street that looked like newly homeless,
some old man.
It looked like,
oh,
you just stop taking your meds.
Like he sought a suit on,
but it was like dingy,
but not to digits.
That's scary.
And just like,
ah,
just like trudging along.
Well,
there are folks who they need something to keep them straight and when they're
off that something,
they're reality becomes really distorted,
especially when they're taking it and then they stopped taking it because
there's a withdrawal where your brain is,
know what the fuck is going on in reality can get really slippery.
They said that 90% of school shootings came from people who are either on Ssri
or we're off them and we're suffering from withdrawal from them.
Yeah.
You know,
we got a PR that's a problem that again,
90% of all schools,
shootings,
90% either came from someone who was on antidepressants or was suffering through
withdrawals from stopping.
Taking them recently was Columbine kids.
They were on him.
You know,
Phil Hartman's wife was on him.
Phil Hartman's wife was on Zoloft and cocaine.
I wonder if I'm on an Ssri or the other one.
I don't know.
She'd probably find out.
Maybe that's making you wacky.
It could be man.
Roadying I've been,
no it's just the TSA.
It's the only time I get.
Wow.
Well that was like Brian and I had a conversation on that.
Brian and I had a conversation about it like,
and you know Brian was like concerned about you and I said he was great with
people like all weekend and he was like super friendly and easy to get along
with.
It's not like you had like,
like all of a sudden.
Yeah,
nothing matters general.
I've never seen it before cause I was like wait,
I know it's a conscious decision.
It wasn't like a reaction to it.
Like let me make a decision here.
Had to get off that one man.
Then maybe I should.
Yeah,
I should get off at one.
Not Good.
You see that Korean Ufo footage that looks real.
That's one of the first check.
Check this out it up here.
This is so real.
Look,
that's signed.
Even Korean didn't make enough noise right now.
Imagine we've found that out right here.
Watch
[inaudible]
you son of a bitch.
I knew it was going to be something not a Ufo.
I thought it would be super fake.
I did not want to watch that.
Don't make lift over.
Don't do that.
Don't do that ever again.
Okay.
For Real.
Scary was scary,
but I don't want you doing that ever again.
I don't like that shit.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Fakey me and making me watch horrific things where I know somebody died.
I don't want to watch that Brian.
That's not a Ufo.
Don't do it.
Definitely knew it was all gone.
You don't do that.
Being around Brian locking up looks man people,
there's certain people don't want to watch certain amount of things.
There's certain shit that is unpleasant and that's one of those things.
It's really unpleasant and he just watched somebody die.
It's scared the fuck out of me.
Yeah,
I've seen a bunch of those.
They terrifying.
And you know what,
if you looked at that and you know,
he said,
aw man,
just drive and we should stop driving.
Like you're not going to stop driving.
You're going to keep driving.
It's just,
it's an unfortunate aberration that happens once every,
you know,
x amount of passages of vehicles is going to be fuck ups and more so now than
ever because people are fucking texting.
There's a sprint APP apparently that keeps you from texting while you're,
your car's in motion.
I don't know what it is,
but I think it's awesome.
It seems like it's a good idea to fucking,
when you get in your car that your car has Bluetooth.
If you get in your car,
I think on modern cars,
your car's Bluetooth should recognize that you're in a car and it should kill
your fucking texting,
but it should be mandatory.
Pasture could suck his dick.
Who Cares?
It's not worth it.
I mean,
it's just not worth it.
People are too crazy.
I saw a guy driving on the fucking four oh five with no hands.
He was texting,
texting with both hands while he was flying down the four oh five and we were
watching them.
Almost everyone does it.
That's what the studies is shown me.
It almost everyone does it and almost everyone who does it looks down on people
who do it.
When to see everybody.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I might look at something at a red light and type something out before the light
turns green real quick.
But I do this every time the light turns green.
I throw it on my passenger seat every time.
Yeah.
It's not worth it.
It's not.
There's not.
I can make phone calls with the little button thing on my phone.
It's great.
You just,
I press a button on my console.
I don't,
I don't have to take my eyes off of anything.
I could press this.
I could press a button on my steering wheel that has a little,
um,
a little phone icon.
I press it and I say,
call Ari Shaffir I fought through that.
No on my steering wheel,
so I don't have to do shit.
Oh.
So as I'm driving,
I pressed the steering wheel.
Go Call Ari Shaffir that's boring.
It just calls you so I don't take my eyes off it.
I don't have to look on my phone.
I have to press that button.
If you have the earphones and you just have to like touch the thing.
Yeah,
that's cool too.
Yeah.
That's nice.
It's helpful.
You can also text people that way.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can.
Yeah,
but Noah people,
no,
don't text routes.
Text Jason Tebow.
Text mom.
Yeah.
Sometimes they're ridiculously off
texts.
The fit Balt you know,
my favorite thing is the,
um,
the Shazaam APP,
the ability to listen to music and tell you what the song is.
That's incredible.
I mean that,
that seems like it's impossible.
I use
it all the time.
If you heard sex with your friends yet,
what's that?
Jamie was talking.
Oh yeah.
It's a plugin that you put on your Facebook and you go through your friends list
and you go,
I would fuck you.
Oh,
I would not fuck you.
Like you just go through like if you would have sex with somebody and then they
put the plug in on their Facebook and they can go through to see all the guys
that would fucker like.
So it's a way to like go hey
also like a friends with benefits thing like the idea is that you need to find
somebody that you have in common.
Is that yeah.
You're not trying to get a relationship but just trying to hook up.
Right?
Like who wants to hook up?
Yeah.
Who wants to hook up and no one else can see it,
but the people that agree.
Yeah.
What someones trolling you scrambled to find people.
Troy,
you almost,
every time I bring a girl back to wherever I'm going,
there's this thought like,
is this a troll?
Are you about to be like,
I lose sleep with you.
Almost every time we have a little insecurity know deep down.
So yeah.
Anyway,
that's the greatest thing.
Then when it girls are really into it though.
You don't meet someone.
Yeah,
you're fucking getting along.
You're great.
You're at dinner or having a laugh.
Ha Ha.
Let me get back to your place and like,
Holy Shit,
it's going to happen the first time it ever happens.
The first time you make it out and you,
Ooh,
she grabs you're cocky,
you're like,
oh my God,
she's into it.
Yeah.
Isn't that wonderful?
That's one of the greatest things about being alive.
It's a pretty magical feeling.
As good as it gets.
It's the problem,
you know,
and people say,
well why would people like lose their,
you know,
leave their wife of 30 years and you know,
new,
fresh got some strange,
that fucking pull is strong.
Jupiter's got a hell of a gravity,
but it can't fuck with pussy.
They'll pull the Jupiter has a shit compared to pussy.
Pussy will make you derail your whole life.
Pushing me into president,
stick his cock and knew a fat girl's mouth.
A little girl just hoping she'll keep it.
She was talking to this with a buddy of mine that he thought about some friend
of his,
some chick fan of his and he goes,
no,
we definitely should not.
Fuck.
That's a good friend of mine for a long time.
And then he said,
you're there and you see you have a chance and you're like,
oh,
maybe this time I'll go for it.
He had a trust is sober self.
Yeah,
the non drunk with pussy self.
We're like no,
you've already thought about this and you're not in your right mind right now.
And that drunk dude listening.
Yeah,
that drunk.
Fuck that part of you.
That's what happened to see inside your head.
It's tough to do anything once it's there.
And this could really happen.
And it's also like genetically you're wired to not just pursue,
but to achieve,
you know,
to achieve copulation it's like,
it's the goal.
It's the goal that your DNA is crop.
You don't,
you,
your DNA is like,
that's the girl that's a girl,
two girls,
girls,
girls.
She was right there and react to it.
She's hugging you and she says it.
She seems to have tits.
Uh,
there's an ass.
Oh my God,
let's get in there.
And then the next thing you know,
you're like,
I can't believe I'm doing this.
Oh my goodness.
It's just,
um,
we're so restrictive in our culture and the way we look at it.
It was when,
it really,
it was really fascinating to having that Guy Christopher Ryan on the podcast,
the guy wrote sex at dawn.
We talked about um,
our ideas of,
of sexuality.
A lot of them are confusing because like our idea of promiscuous,
like we'd look at like,
um,
people that are in non monogamous relationships as being promiscuous.
Yeah.
So like if you think of promiscuity,
think of like,
especially with girls,
you think of someone who goes out and fucks a lot of guys and it's like shallow
relationships,
boom.
That's not the original meaning of permissiveness that their original meanings
based on Latin or whatever the word for mixed.
And the idea was that people in small tribes of like 50 people would have sexual
relationships with more than one person before they knew these people very well
their whole life.
They knew these people.
So it wasn't that they were just having random sex with strangers because no one
ever does that in those tribes.
You don't meet someone in another tribe and because they might kill you and eat
you.
You know,
cause if you ran into another tribe and they weren't your people there,
they could be the enemy.
I mean,
they're not going to treat you the way you would go to Finland today.
Hop on a plane land and like,
you know,
get your shit and go to an airport and nobody knows you.
You're not from there.
But they're like,
Hello Matt,
help you.
And you're like,
yeah,
I doing.
They would just beat the fuck out of you and kill you.
Like when people would run into people that they didn't know,
they automatically,
as soon as people were up to no good.
So there wasn't a very little promiscuity in that sense.
An early man.
How many school shooters are there been?
It's been quite a few.
And by the way,
they go way back to like the 1930s.
Really?
Yeah.
They'd go back even before that,
I believe,
uh,
early.
Okay.
Let's find out.
We should know earliest school shooting.
Wow.
Yeah.
The government has been using school shootings for reasons for since the 1930s
or the first school shooting was in Canada.
Why?
Wait a minute now.
Hold on a second.
Oh my God.
Older than America.
It took place in 1764 what?
Some dude just shot some like a kid or a teacher or something and someone shot
or Pennsylvania teacher in front of the class.
1764 so this was before America was like,
officially I don't have that as a school shooting.
Well,
the first assassination in school,
I mean,
that's just the first one.
They're counting when the kids start getting killed.
Right.
It's more,
oh yeah.
Well that was Columbine.
I think that was the first one,
wasn't it?
No,
because like wasn't the someone that some sniper,
the tower,
Canton,
Ohio.
Kent state was the National Guard.
Yeah.
That was the actual,
the government with sharp shooting protesters.
Um,
yeah,
there's,
there's been a lot man,
like,
okay.
Columbia,
South Carolina,
a boy armed with a gun killed of his schoolmates and severely wounded.
Several others presumably firing upon them in retaliation for bullying.
He expressed no regret for his deed or miss was 1890.
Wow.
All right,
well that counts.
That's exactly what we're talking about.
1890.
Um,
you know Kevin's namaste.
That's all right.
No,
you know what man,
bullying makes you depressed as fuck though.
Is that the way out from under it?
Plus your experience is so limited as a,
as a young child that you think this is what my life is going to be like
forever.
A terrific.
And the people who are doing it,
they get caught up in a pattern of doing it and I,
you know,
it's,
they,
they need to be checked as well.
Yeah.
In 1891,
a seven year old man fired a shotgun at students in a school playground in
Newburgh,
New York.
In 1946,
a 15 year old student was shot in the basement where Brooklyn school by seven
thugs school shootings are not a new phenomenon.
Yeah.
They,
um,
they've been so kind of,
they have 90% of people that aren't Ssri.
It's one or they can come in and as her eyes,
um,
I dunno.
I Dunno when it,
well let's,
let's look that up.
School shootings and Ssri.
So it's like that out to Canada is 90% maybe that accounts for 90%.
Maybe as soon as the SSRI I've kicked in
Canada just released new money and they,
you know,
they're melt in the sun.
No,
no,
but the paper or that the,
what is it?
The,
the maple leaf is their national whatever leaf.
Yeah.
And they've got the wrong leaf.
They printed the wrong leaf on the marijuana leaf.
It's like something crazy like nor do nor Regeneron exact time.
Yeah.
I just took a picture.
I don't maple leaf [inaudible] argument.
The SSRI is that it's not,
um,
it's not the cause and that it's just a symptom of the fact these people were
depressed in the first place.
Willing to do that.
There's so many doctors at a will end up prescribing these things and not
necessarily caused by Ssri that that's a,
that is an argument.
The only problem with that argument is that one of the,
the very effects of antidepressants is the fact that you,
you can just deal with shit easier.
It makes things easier to deal with.
It like lessens their impact on you,
makes them feel less real or make you more likely to be able to bless.
It makes it feels less real.
It was fucking blasting people over 66 school shootings involve SSRI drugs.
If it's 66 school shootings,
that's a lot.
Yeah,
it's pretty scary.
Shit,
man.
You know,
the real thing is,
um,
what's,
what's really scary is the amount of people that are medicated in this country
and the lack of information we have about the longterm effects of some of this
medication.
There's no one has been on antidepressants for 80 years.
No one's,
no one's been on in their whole life.
No one even knows if he can do that.
If you've got 80 years,
start seeing symptoms.
Yeah.
That's not bad.
I guess.
I don't think anybody's really doing it though.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
how many,
how long they been around?
Um,
I think eighties.
Yeah.
I don't know about before that 8.0 earthquake and in,
in easier,
right now there's a huge tsunami.
Oh,
okay.
If you're stuck in Indonesia,
uh,
get my special,
um,
passive aggressive are you goes out,
you're talking goes out title.
Use the solar power to download.
Download it for just 489 right now.
Yeah.
I'm looking at these,
uh,
these shootings.
Yeah.
The uh,
it's,
it's pretty scary when you go over all the different ones.
The real,
the,
what's going on.
No,
no,
no doubt about it.
Is that there's too many fucking people no doubt about that.
So you're going to have a nominee of law.
More of them.
We've lost our value.
Okay.
There's so many of us that we,
we've lost our value and we lost our uniqueness.
We've lost our values,
our value.
Yeah.
We don't,
we're not worth as much and people get stuck in the,
to a school system and someone's not paying attention and someone allows that
person to get victimized and become a horrific monster because they're there,
they get bullied and they get fucked with.
That is the case a lot of the time.
Man,
that is the case a lot of the fucking time.
And that's someone who doesn't feel like they have any value.
And if you want to unleash that,
that,
that feeling of lack of value on other people and they want to do something
horrible because they feel terrible themselves.
Yeah.
We have to figure out a way to,
to,
even though we are in a community of 300 million people,
we have to readjust.
Re-Install the ideas of community,
of being nice to each other.
I want those people to be captured alive.
I want to be able to talk to them and say the shooter school shooters.
Oh,
and be like,
what's going through your head beforehand?
Sky was what type of
Rosie really wasn't it?
Which last?
Um,
shooter was cat.
No new town.
He's dead.
Oh,
the cow.
I'm Aurora.
Colorado guy is a lot.
Columbine?
No,
no.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The movie theater guys alive.
Oh yeah.
What's he saying?
Oh,
here's this school shooter and candidate gets dead though,
right?
Yeah.
Did he kill himself?
I think he killed himself.
Colorado kids tried to kill himself a few times.
The Colorado kids tried to kill himself while in,
in the jail,
but it has the,
does the new count the kid,
did they kill him?
I think he might have killed him,
but I don't know.
We should we look at that out there was something I remember recently of like of
like a,
why do all these people kill themselves right off today?
Uh,
yeah.
Well they say that once they get engaged by someone who is,
yeah,
they'll kill themselves.
I just want to flip damage or something.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
I don't know if this guy's alive or not.
I Dunno if he's dead.
I think he's gone.
I would've,
we would've heard about him,
right?
I Dunno.
New towns shooter.
I wrote new towns shooter dead and nothing came up.
No.
Essentially was a cause of death.
Okay.
I bet they'll say gunshot wound self-inflicted.
Yeah.
Cause to the temple.
Hmm.
What Brian?
Nothing.
You're fun in Vegas?
No.
You went hard.
Yeah.
Okay.
His name is Adam Lanza.
Right.
So let's,
yeah,
you went,
yeah.
Yeah.
He went away hard this week.
The last train.
Pete on his own pillow.
Oh yeah,
Jordy talking about that.
What kind of touched on it yesterday?
What I don't understand is why you always wet and I still laid on it for a good
hour.
Like I've woke up like why is it wet dude?
I woke up in La Jolla condo once and it was barf on the,
on the,
on the sheets right next to me like under the,
and I was so sure that someone had done that from the week before.
I just hadn't seen it when I went to sleep that I called up like who was in the
condo and they were like Whitney and I was like,
what need did you barf from vet?
She goes,
no,
I didn't even actually stay there.
I think Katie stayed there.
I just went home.
I was like,
Katie,
did you borrow from the bed?
He goes,
no,
what do you mean?
I really didn't even drink or anything and I was like,
mother Fucker,
I barfed in the bed.
I didn't know.
Oh my God damn it.
That's dangerous.
I know.
I know you're done.
Your sleep absolutely killed.
This guy killed himself.
He did.
Yeah.
The new town.
As soon as the first responders arrived,
he blew his brains out.
And I'd like to hear it like the guy in Colorado didn't though.
Like I was alive still.
He's supposed to be batshit crazy.
Not even like have any sort of semblance of like,
well,
I believe he was medicated and who knows what he's on now.
Uh,
whole experience of being an isolated,
solitary confinement like that for long periods of time.
You know,
there's something that does,
he really breaks in a person's brain when they remove them from human
interaction.
Yeah.
It's fucking really dangerous.
They say that,
that uh,
um,
South American five minutes,
one of the worst tortures you can give somebody.
Yeah.
That Bradley Manning kid is kind of fucked because of that.
Not to ever recover.
Probably not.
It's probably broken.
They're going to execute him and uh,
I bet they would like to just disappear,
make him disappear.
But too many people are aware of him.
You know,
I mean there's all these campaigns and all over online Twitter followers and d
two Twitter accounts dies now.
They'll be like,
no way did he die.
Well he's going through some sort of a legal process right now.
You know me already.
Yeah.
And I think they're,
they're,
they're actually responding to the idea that maybe what they did to him was
cruel and inhuman.
The,
you know.
Yeah.
It's Kinda crazy cause all the guy did was let everybody know that the
government did some really shady shit and this guy's being treated like he's a
mass murderer.
People who have killed people get better treatment than this guy.
People who have murdered people with their bare hands get better treatment.
And this guy who thought he was being a patriot.
And you know,
the real issue that people have to come to grips with is part of the idea of
liberty is that you're defending yourself against enemies,
both foreign and domestic.
You know,
it depends what you got to look at.
Corruption being domestic enemies.
It's,
I mean it is if,
if,
if it's secretive and you can hide the information from the public,
but if the public saw that information,
they would be aghast and horrified.
Well,
that information is stopping them from evaluating the actual landscape,
the actual landscape that they're playing on the actual rules of the game,
the actual board in front of them because they don't really see that.
And by removing the information that's in involved in war,
by removing the bodies,
the,
the real video footage,
then you,
you,
you remove access to more of the truth that would help people decide whether or
not they support that or not support that.
That in just by itself,
that lack of information,
that withholding of information is,
is there decision decisions that the public doesn't need this security and it's
contrary to the ideas of freedom.
The idea of,
yeah,
the idea that also the idea that if we're informed and then we could debate on
this,
we could decide what we all want.
Instead,
we're being led.
And one of the ways that are leading us is by withholding information,
but they also have,
they can't,
they can't lie,
like covert operations people.
Right.
Let's stop.
That's why Wiki leaks didn't do any of that.
Wikileaks responded the way real journalism is sort of this to work.
They didn't release anybody's name who hadn't already been compromised.
They didn't put anybody's life in jeopardy.
What they did was they released video footage.
It showed a fucking,
a patchy helicopter shooting down whatever the fuck those rounds were just
ripping people apart.
That turned out to be reporters that they won't let you.
Oh,
there's reporters.
The fact that won't let you show,
um,
bodies coming home.
Yeah.
It felt like,
yeah.
That was during the Bush administration.
They stopped that photographing coffins because morale up because life magazine
could show the,
the,
the actual magnitude or those coffins,
you would freak the fuck out if this is what we should be allowed to freak the
fuck out.
[inaudible] yeah,
but that would make you squeamish about the war.
So listen,
we've already started this.
We've got to get things done and best way to get things done is to keep the
American public.
A lone man.
Things get things done is to have no one die.
Yeah,
but that's not going to happen because nobody wants to just give up their oil.
So yeah.
So then we have to see those things to listen to bother your ears.
When you have monitor a long time,
they're a little tight and you've got well wearing for a long time we might have
to switch to something a little more comfortable,
like I'm a great headphones.
Then I just like,
it seems like it like after about two hours I start getting like my ears for
like,
I have glasses too.
Maybe we should hit it.
Oh,
that's probably what it is.
Maybe we should just put them on and do a podcast until our ears bother us and
that will be the way we stopped podcasts.
That's a good idea.
I just feel like this podcast was so negative in the beginning.
I know it's talk about poop.
Okay,
that's not what you're saying.
Let's talk about my special,
can we talk about that for a minute?
Sure.
Well,
the fact that we're all,
and you are to doing these self-release specials.
Yeah.
What do you think of all the beautiful,
I mean,
obviously I'm a big fan of releasing content on the Internet.
This,
this whole podcast is changed all of our lives,
not just my life.
It's changed Joey's life.
Dunkin's live,
you're births
life,
Brian's life,
everybody's life.
It's just,
it's a new thing.
And the ability to release things online like that is,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
I don't think,
um,
there's a better way to,
to get something directly to your fans.
The only issue is,
um,
I think that something like comedy central is awesome for getting you new fans.
Yeah.
It looks like you put a special out,
but I think you could probably wind up selling your content to comedy.
You do it yourself and then sell to your friends in six,
eight months later,
a year later.
Then you put it out on a network and then say,
okay,
anyway,
new wants to check this out.
Yeah.
By all means.
And,
but the real thing is that you should own it.
And you're right.
That's why you own it.
You can decide what gets done with it.
And if you have a central wants to cuddle up to all hell and say we're going to
air it this way,
you can be like,
Nah,
yeah man,
I don't take that.
Yeah.
And you know,
and you could always have it available in its full,
an unadulterated form on your website to get it six years from now they can just
get it instead of having to wait for a network to aerate against.
Yeah.
And I love it.
It's only five bucks.
Five bucks is perfect to get up a couple different downloads you get to
streaming.
It's half the price,
super easy and third and it's good.
And the thing about,
um,
these things is to,
I'm starting to treat it like a,
like an art project and I get excited.
You get excited about building a new one.
I get excited about new subjects and new bits and putting things together and
I'm excited about taking this,
you know,
our I'm doing right now and tightening it up to like perfect form print Jarvis,
I'm gonna release this new bitch in July I think.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think that's um,
was like 15 months.
The great wave on this time.
It was a 20 years.
You can do it on your own schedule so you don't have to be like,
oh,
I get some that would say instead of saying now,
I mean after your first special,
it's so great on comedy central.
Yeah.
You wanted to do one like a year and a half later.
They didn't want me doing one a year later we wanted to wait.
They wanted to wait three years and you're like,
but I'm ready.
Yeah.
And you don't have to wait on anybody else's schedule.
Well I think I understand it from their point of view.
You know,
they only have so many hours in a week and you know,
why should they put out another one of my specials?
You know,
even if it's good,
why are they doing that?
Maybe if I had one of their shows,
like if I was on a comedy central show and they were,
it would help,
you know,
cross promote but I don't.
So it doesn't really help them.
Yeah.
You have this other dissemination vehicle.
That'd be cool too.
I'll do a couple of these on my own and then a year later I'll go to comedy
central and say,
Hey,
you know,
you guys want to do another and then maybe I could do one there and then I'll do
it.
I'll do it both ways.
Do you just in your own,
you know,
I may give it to him later.
Yeah.
Or do it on my own and sell it to them.
Everybody wants content.
It's a,
it's a beautiful thing to be able to put out shit online like that.
Look at you,
you wear a nice shirt and everything.
It's a button down and vice versions of me don't play any of his material,
man.
You'll ruin it if it's true.
It was the trailer.
Um,
the best thing about it,
and I don't know how much you did stuff on,
uh,
on TV before,
but nobody tells you what to say.
Oh yeah.
I love that.
Well,
you know what,
that has monkey's in space to really,
yeah,
because I was under the zoo umbrella and so they told you all,
I did it all through the UFC.
We produced it.
So you were allowed to do whatever you want.
Yeah,
because it was on,
spike was on spike TV and you know,
back when the UFC was dominating spike TV,
the worst bike.
Yeah.
I mean spike was like,
they were like our good friends and you know,
it was really easy to do a special with them.
They,
they had already seen me do stand up a hundred times because when we would do
these shows,
like spike guys would come to the fights.
Yeah.
So it was,
um,
it was super easy.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Yeah,
it was talked about it.
Yeah.
It was a,
it was really easy to do that.
So I the the spike thing.
We also did it with like Herod after a UFC,
so that was awesome.
Oh yeah.
That's where it followed.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Follow.
It was mass like that showed that lands.
Yeah.
It was like 1.7 million people watched or something.
Wow.
Yeah.
Did you see a bump and turn out like after that?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It definitely was a bunch of new people found out you were combat because I mean
a lot of people just didn't even know if I was any good.
You know,
it's like we've seen a lot of people that are on TV that do stand up and then
you go see them and you're like,
oh,
this is like a monkey shitty standard.
Yeah.
Know that I've been doing standup for that long.
You know,
a lot of people,
like I was like,
I could have been a beginner,
like they weren't sure,
but I was lucky.
No clue that it was,
you know,
I'd been doing it for long enough that it would actually,
it would make sense to go see and pay money for it.
Jeff props was a comic,
but maybe,
but then you go see him if it was like,
we've,
I don't want to,
I'm trying to,
I,
the reason why I'm awkward with my words here is I'm trying to dance around the,
the closing.
Yeah.
Trying to be nice,
but when I think,
uh,
as a standup comic,
you need like 10 years.
Yeah.
10 years until you're really a comic.
It takes at least that long or close to it as a range.
I'm sure some people are sick,
some people or 15,
but that's the average.
I could see that to be able to put out like an hour special it really 10 years
is probably pretty smart.
It's probably a good amount of time to get your shit first.
He told me this early on,
you're like,
I don't do shit for my first few years.
All I do is Arnold.
That's the only thing that Phil lasted.
Just a quick save or joke.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The rest is all gone.
So it was like you're just learning ability.
Yeah.
You're learning how to get laughs.
The Mike.
So you're really important for young guys.
I always tell people like those clunky jokes that you know,
everybody has an act where,
um,
I mean I'm not,
not everybody,
but a lot of comics,
they have an act where they have this like a couple killer bits and they have a
few bits that are just left over from the old days.
I'm like,
you got to get rid of those.
Dangerous,
they're dangerous because like when you have like a really shitty joke like
that,
that Shitty joke is a,
it's an echo of your lack of proficiency in the early parts of your career and
you're sort of repeating that echo,
why do you still have this?
You've got to abandon that.
Yeah.
You've got to abandon that and sort of,
you know,
filling that time with your new perceptions,
filling that time with unique.
So if you have some old shit that's still stuck in there because it's like a
tool that you're used to using.
That's why I like this,
this,
you know,
a special year,
year and a half years.
So almost like,
hey,
this is what I'm going through.
2012,
of course,
aggressive.
That's what I,
that was what was happening in my life at 2012.
How much did it force you to actually sit down and write things?
Cause I know you actually got an office.
Oh yeah.
Well I used the office a lot or I use it sometimes and I started on the road a
lot and then I just couldn't use it as much,
right back for two days or whatever and I wouldn't go over there.
So he stopped using it.
Yeah.
But what it made me really do is be real cognizant of like not wasting a comedy
store set,
not just like,
oh,
I'll just run it,
run some lines,
have already done before.
It's like work on something.
Right.
What are you doing here?
Because you've got to build five minutes this month.
You've got to have five minutes at spot.
So where are you going,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
so I kept that marker in line.
So because you can get so complacent,
so easily.
Like,
Hey,
I'm doing fine,
I'm doing fine.
And then all of a sudden three years passed and you're still doing the same
material.
Yeah,
it was a month in two months,
then years.
And then you are force yourself to,
and he,
George Carlin,
I mean everybody really owes it to him.
He was the only guy that ever was doing that.
It was doing it every year.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
But why not?
Why not go through it?
Ever Picasso had his blue period,
you know,
it's like you'll see the development of a person as a human through their
material.
Well,
well you got to realize a certain point in time is that you are the only person
who can put out Ari Shaffir material.
So if someone's an Ari Shaffir Fan,
you're the only way that they can get that experience.
If they enjoy watching you and they,
they uh,
oh,
I saw Ari Shaffir and the way he made me feel,
boy,
I became a fan.
You know,
when you become a fan of somebody,
it's like you want more fucking content from that person.
And the reality is if you go to see a guy and you go to cm six years later and
he's doing the same act in the same order,
you're not going to be a fan anymore.
The same order.
It's,
we've all seen it.
I don't want to say any names again,
but I was watching this a showtime thing or mine invited me,
showtime,
one of those networks and it was standup comedy and it was a guy that I knew on
it and I'm like,
this motherfucker did not just do that bit.
He was doing that bit 15 years ago.
She'll tell me it's got better specials.
They need to invest in a better type of comedy.
You have such good fucking show,
such good shows,
but weeds and,
and,
and California k they have cool shows.
So why their specials dog?
She's gotta be a different guy in charge of that.
But then not all dog shit.
They put Stan hopes on Stan hopes.
Um,
I put it right here.
They're putting my a 2005 one on.
Really?
I just want to tell you it wasn't dog shit.
No,
you're right.
But he's sweating just a lot of what they put on.
I'll tell you right now.
Um,
a lot of what they put on it didn't need to open Williams on did they put Katt
Williams on or is it um,
cat apocalypse?
Was that HBO or showtime?
Was it showtime?
I think it was showtime.
All those,
the Greeks of combat blacklist is pretty good.
And the,
and the like,
the theme shows that Scott,
my toy puts out,
oh,
sorry about that stuff.
Should never make it to the air.
They should be illegal.
Legal team shows,
hey,
we're all Chinese.
Get get the fuck Outta here.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You assholes.
Hey,
we're all from Spain.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
They,
they tried to get me to do the all Guinea shows,
these silly the store.
I was like,
are you crazy?
First of all,
I wasn't Guido's yeah.
my last name is Irish.
Okay.
Only three quarters,
Italian and second off,
a second of all,
I'm a time,
I'm not sharing the stage of these current bags just cause we are an origins.
They all end up doing the same jokes.
Yeah.
Cause it has to be about all the Arabs are all the,
I'll let him telling me,
well I'll do the Arab accent out of the way.
Get it out of there and then triple he goes on to those shows and I was like,
I'm just going to talk about fucking chicks and cars.
Yeah.
We,
they love Yay.
Different Aaa.
I love that guy.
He's so silly.
Yeah.
It's,
hey,
have you heard about this?
You stuff?
What?
What's going on?
Paying no Pang.
Oh No.
What's happening?
Well,
I am revolt
three quarters of the way through that book about the comedy.
So I strike in [inaudible] 79.
So tell me about that book.
What is it called?
It's amazing.
Um,
not that they've,
the laughter died.
It was,
I'm dying up here.
Yeah.
Is that what it was?
I think so.
I'm dying up here.
Yeah.
I was just about a guy who was embedded with them,
a journalist who was embedded with them.
Yeah.
I thought the 40 comics that were around at the time and how they started
getting pissed at,
um,
a lot of them couldn't afford food.
Yeah.
That was an interesting story.
So Tom,
Jason was,
uh,
was,
it was only a laugh factory conflict now I guess,
but he was making like a few hundred grand a year.
They should be where people came from too.
Like,
you know,
he came from Chicago,
I think work in clubs there.
So he got to the store,
got in making a few hundred grand a year and then all did a new year's show,
two sold out shows and the Orr,
maybe one of the main room.
And this kid,
one of them who's on that New Year's show,
uh,
they all went to canter's late at night every night.
And he's like,
Hey,
can I borrow $5 for an Omelet?
I don't have any money.
And he was like,
yeah,
no problem.
But then he was like,
fuck,
how can you not afford an Omelet?
That doesn't make any sense.
You just did a sold out new year's show,
but the comics weren't getting paid anything.
The waitress has got paid.
The fucking,
the people who cleaned the toilets got paid.
Comics didn't get paid anything.
And that UCB right now it's coming out.
It's like if they're not paying,
they're packed every night and they're charging $5 cover charges and the comics
don't get,
don't get anything.
I don't get anything.
Yeah.
Why don't they get anything?
I've heard one stance is like,
well,
it's a showcase is really a popular club and you,
if you don't like performing here at same thing as you know.
Other reasons,
not a good reason.
If you don't like performing here,
then don't perform.
You know?
If you don't like the exposure you're getting,
but it's like,
yes I am getting exposure.
You're getting UCB has people go into it?
Yeah,
but you're selling comedy.
But it's like I would get that exposure if you charge zero.
So the fact that you're charging five right?
Shouldn't.
And how about,
don't you like that?
These awesome comics is Zach Galifianakis will show up at your club.
Don't you like that?
Yeah.
You get something out of that.
So give them 20 bucks.
Yeah,
it's totally unfair way to look at it.
The idea that you're getting exposure so you should work for free.
That's something that the club was not getting anything.
Yeah.
Well that was the store's argument.
The store's argument was always at the store is the star and that you should be
happy that you're performing at the store.
Like I had this conversation with them about that.
Once I go,
listen,
I go,
you guys have a box with a microphone in it and you know what you sell,
you sell what we think up.
That's what you sell.
And if we're not there and we're not performing,
guess what?
You have no show and no one's going to buy your fucking $20 Heineken's cause
that's not how it works.
It's not how it works.
You're,
you're,
you're confused and no one's going there and saying,
oh my God,
this is amazing.
Unless you're giving tours of the place.
Well,
if you're giving tours of the place,
that's the only the only know the value is in the history of the place.
That's it.
But when you're showing,
when you have shows you you're not,
no one's going there because it's this awesome old place.
They're going there because it's awesome.
I'll place that has fucked nominee and the deal is,
it's like no one's saying the commerce,
no commerce are saying we want all the money because the club does offer you
something.
It offers you that box office you workout,
but it's a mutually beneficial,
some level of split and it shouldn't be zero.
It shouldn't be zero.
No,
it's ridiculous.
I mean,
I didn't mind it being zero when I was making a lot of money in TV shows out
there.
It's your choice to keep my money,
but it was my choice to help promote the club and keep it going because I
realized as a comic I need a place like that.
We all need it and I,
it helps.
As long as that place was open and it was,
we could go onstage.
It was good for all of us.
So I felt like it's what you have,
what you should do is do you realize that weren't,
they weren't making millions of dollars,
they were struggling.
So I'm like,
well I'll help.
I'll help cause I like this.
Yeah.
They were barely staying in business.
So I'm like,
I'll help because I can't.
Yeah.
So it was the right thing to do.
But the wrong thing to do is to think that you owe them that and that somehow or
another you should work for free.
You don't want that.
Somehow or another you're getting exposure.
Like your whole thing is selling common.
And he said also it was like,
it was a workout class at the time.
The store,
not that UCB,
but at a time,
the store,
they said that's a workout room.
They don't want it to be about you,
your pay for comedy.
So you have to feel like you have to do something.
But then they should put it in Pasadena.
Well,
but then they said this,
they said,
um,
Boosler Elaine Boosler was like the one girl comic at the time was um,
I got to watch some of her old stuff because the way they make her see him in
this book,
like she was like pretty legit.
She's legit and I don't really know any of her material.
She was legit.
It's definitely time.
But yeah,
she was definitely legit.
But she said,
she said,
well,
wait a minute,
I've heard Mitzi say no to somebody because they were too experimental.
So how can we tell me to be too experimental?
And also it could be a workout club.
Well,
worse off than that.
I mean,
no,
it's not a workout
club because it was constantly visited by age.
My manager know with Derek [inaudible] you didn't really work out because if you
ate dick up there,
that could be,
they're not kind of that someone saw you and you bought.
Whereas like if you go to a place like Pasadena,
like you could try out some shit out there because most likely it's 20 minutes
outside of La.
It wouldn't get agents or Irvine.
No,
it's actually the exact opposite.
And one of the most invaluable tools I have is Tuesdays and Wednesdays at the
comedy store.
You don't even have time at the talent coordinator there,
you know,
it's early in the week,
so nobody really cares.
And it's like full impunity to bomb,
you know,
with,
with full employment though,
you can just go,
you can just be bad.
Right.
Not you're,
you're trying to be,
but like there's no stakes for failing.
So it allows you to try some shit and it's empty.
Yeah.
There might be 15 people there,
you know,
so it's like,
I'm going to work on some things right now.
That's ridiculous.
20 million people in La and they can only get 15 that is some of the most
incompetent shit.
And the history of the universe,
the way they run that fucking place,
the implant doesn't bring her show every night.
Well listen,
it's a lot of them,
there's a lot of them,
but even on the bringer shows the Improv,
they'll still get a crowd.
Yeah.
Surprise me.
Sometimes on Tuesdays,
Wednesdays,
last few years have been a lot better.
We could organize.
I mean,
I think we do it every time.
We do shows at the ice house.
You know,
we,
we pack the Ice House on a Wednesday night at 10:00 PM show and we have 200
people stuffed into that place.
We do it all the time.
If we organized and you know,
had a,
like a place where everybody,
everybody went out at a regular basis and,
and split the revenue with the comedians figuring out a weird revenue at GM.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just figuring out,
okay,
this what is,
how much does it cost us to keep open,
which would cost that much as much.
It costs this much to buy food.
So let's also,
let's set this aside and then let's figure out how much profit there is and then
let's split it all.
Let's figure out a way to make it legit.
Where,
you know,
the comics,
it's benefits them to work there,
but that'd be it after Topia.
Yeah,
I think that's possible.
I think an artist's utopia is possible.
So much competition to get into a club like that.
Yeah.
Well there's already competition now.
I mean that people,
there was a duty waited in line at the fucking ice house waiting in line.
You know,
cause I always take pictures with people afterwards.
The guy was a comic,
waited in line to the very end.
I told you and he asked me how he gets on the show.
I'm like,
you don't,
you know,
I've got to be my friend.
You know,
I don't know you some dude,
he's just started to do comedy.
You can't just like get in here.
These are sold out shows and there's seven of us,
you know?
And there's,
you're dealing with Greg Fitzsimmons,
Brian Cowen,
you,
Joey Diaz mean they're,
they're murderers.
Murder after murderer.
Like you can't just slide in there with your shitty five minutes on doughnuts
and cops.
Yeah.
Like I said,
yeah,
but the only they see as themselves like I want it.
Right.
You're like,
I know,
but
what do you remember that feeling,
man?
Fuck yeah.
You remember that feeling when you just,
you were so delusional on stage.
Good enough.
Why can't I get on?
Because it's got nothing to do with that right now.
Yeah.
And some of them you talked to and you just know they a dick.
Peter Chan
used to do that.
He used to complain about not getting on stage and he goes,
but I've been there for 10 years.
I was like Bababa shut,
done,
get spots.
Either he goes,
but he only been here eight years.
I've been there 10 years so me and I'll be like,
oh you're crazy person though.
You are missing the point.
Peter Chan was the only guy that I bought.
I actually hosted over
to keep Peter Chen from hosting at one night cause McGuire was,
because my friend Chris Mcguire was going to,
he was going to audition for myths and writer of the Barn and I knew that if
this fucking,
if this guy was hosting it,
I'm like Mcguire's going to have no chance because there's going to be no show.
It's going to be just death.
He's such a terrible,
terrible comedian that if he was hosting it,
there's no way he would generate any laughs.
It would set the tone for the entire night.
No one will be having fun.
It wouldn't be,
it wouldn't be good.
So at the height of fear factor?
Yeah,
the open mic at 7:00 PM there all day.
All the employees.
It was pretty Rad for us.
It was just an employee for like fucking Joe Rogan is hosting tonight.
What the fuck?
It was fun to do and it works.
Chris got past,
you know,
it's like he never got any,
did really like that spots though.
It was like one of those things where he wanted them to just hang out and call
in.
Like you pass him and then either,
I don't really use them.
They know.
You know how it is at the store.
The store wants you there.
You got to hang out.
You gotta be a part of the furniture dude.
I know you used to fucking,
I used to love that.
So when you hung out on employee nights on Sunday or Monday,
I loved it too.
I just love hanging out there.
We would do,
we do a night where everyone tried to each other's material,
all the employees,
but were like,
we'd have to pick out of a hat because of who you get.
And I remember watching it.
Just laughing.
That was fun.
Those are fun shit.
Yeah,
I remember a,
what the fuck is his name?
The dude who was really funny.
It doesn't do comedy anymore.
Um,
pick her up.
Our gym painter,
painter,
painter.
Yeah.
What he stopped doing comedy?
He's another one where I was like,
man,
this guy is funny man.
He was gonna make it.
He's going to make it.
He's,
he's solid.
And I'm like,
I could see this guy just crushing a tell style on the road.
And then for whatever reason it's,
it's a very delicate thing that that makes a comic,
especially just for a few years,
you're out his way through.
You're not getting any validation.
It's only reason you're doing this for validation.
I always wonder like what is it about like certain Comedians,
Robert Ward,
what is it about certain comedians that just like really crack through and what
is it about certain comedians like you know,
I always talk about Reggie Big Fab and then brilliant regimen fraud and was in
the nineties you know,
and then I ran into a Kevin Hart the other day in my neighborhood actually is
the first time I ever met him.
Super Nice Guy.
Super Nice,
super cool.
Super friendly.
Like really genuine.
Like you could tell like right away,
like really cool car.
Yeah.
And he can't,
he can't be any bigger than that guy.
Yeah.
He's like Dane Cook was when he was at its peak.
That's where Kevin Hart is right now.
Maybe even a little bigger.
Possibly.
Yeah.
Pyrotechnics.
He made me even a little bigger because he's doing comedy movies like dude doing
movies of his standup and he's doing legit movies that are actually funny.
Or as Dane Cook's movies,
we're all dog shit.
Yeah.
He just did dog shit movie after dog shit movie.
I mean,
I think he did like them or played a serial killer once.
That was probably a pretty good,
I heard it was pretty good.
I heard that too,
but I don't know.
I didn't say it,
but I saw a couple of them that were like,
they were like,
it was almost like the,
the aliens were trying to replicate it,
human beings for the invasion of the body snatchers,
which by the way,
I watched the other day,
I watched two versions.
I watched one of them for the 1950s,
which was really weird.
And then,
uh,
I watched the other one from 1978 with Donald Sutherland,
which was fucking awesome early.
It was really good.
It totally holds up.
Yeah.
Did you,
you remember it?
Yeah.
It really holds up really.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It's some of the 70s horror movies cause it's so grainy that it lends itself
since it's old.
Yeah.
Passivity more legit as opposed to as special effects movie with mince.
It makes it less legit.
Well I watched it with Mrs [inaudible] and we were like,
wow,
this is really interesting.
It's like,
it's such a different style of film.
Like the way they did Jeff Goldbloom is in,
I forgot Jeff Goldbloom,
isn't it?
Yeah,
he's so young and skinny.
It's really what he was like a pencil I like.
And those guys that were stars for,
you know,
a billion years.
And you see them Monday when they started?
Yeah.
Like the girl from sex and the city when she was in La Story.
Yeah,
of course.
Face one.
Yeah.
How is she famous?
You see them,
their first roles.
You're like,
oh,
I get it when you were a young fucking rambunctious 26 year olds and you look
fucking great.
Yeah.
You know,
he's like,
I totally get it now.
You're just,
Kim could trawl the slot and the sex and the city.
When she was young,
she was unbelievably hot.
If it's a pretty hot at 50,
I fucked her 54 and it was,
it was kind of,
do you know anybody who did know?
I know,
uh,
yeah.
Maybe I should stop.
What will,
you can just change the names to protect the innocent,
but then it wouldn't be as fun.
Well tell me what you got going on.
I don't know what he's saying.
Well,
I know someone who boned like an eighties.
Humongous star.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
who's The star?
That's a problem.
I don't know if I should say,
even though it comes around once in a while.
Oh,
okay.
Don't say it.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
How big a star.
Pretty big.
Yeah.
I'll tell you afterwards.
Okay.
Damn.
This doesn't help the podcast though.
And you can all pressure him into telling you who is it?
Nick Yusuf Nick.
I liked Nikki.
Who is bone.
Good man.
He'll tell us maybe,
but does he still hitting it?
Is that what it is?
It's been a long time.
But uh,
how old is this?
This young Gal now,
can we play a game?
Can we gas?
Can you,
can you,
uh,
give us some wrong,
hold on.
Let me do the math in my head.
If I'm allowed to.
Like she likes her license means it's coming out.
If we do that.
So I'm not even thinking about this.
The math in your head or whether or not you can get in trouble,
whether or not this is not the cool or is okay,
well there's nothing wrong with a little sacks and unless a,
that's an excellent point.
She's not supposed to do that.
That's totally cool.
And everybody's part.
I mean it's not like,
okay,
let's play the guessing game.
She likes Reese's pieces.
So I'm assuming yes.
I don't know.
Idea.
Let me get her,
um,
Wikipedia page.
Um hmm.
She have a lot of stuffed animals in a closet.
I don't know.
I haven't had any,
my sister knew
there's a,
by the way,
while we're on the,
on the way to doing this,
uh,
I've talked to you about 51 now.
Okay.
What,
what does she do?
She's in a lot of music videos.
She's a singer.
Paul Abdul.
He fuck you.
Fuck Paul Abdul.
No,
he wouldn't fucking Jew.
Oh,
those are jus the good cause.
The theory and kind.
It's like the really good kind of,
does that mean the hot,
don't look Hardik Jews.
They look more like Persian.
Like Israelis.
Israelis really have a lot more as far Jews,
but it a lot of Ashkenazi Jews there.
But yeah,
they're all intermingled.
Ashkenazi.
They'd be telling my dad,
I guess word but some somebody since he's Ashkenazi,
he uh,
him and his friend puts somebody in the hospital for dating.
His sister was far guy.
Oh my God.
Cause no fucking Sardi is going to date my sister.
Why hidden is wow.
Yeah.
They beat somebody as a Douche bag.
I tell him now he's like,
I know it was very stupid.
I get,
I'm watching both.
Is it,
cause I get it.
I know now why I was 16.
How am I supposed send out?
Oh,
so there's a new thing called the human brain project.
Yeah.
Check this out.
And they are putting together all the existing no knowledge about the human
brain and they're trying to reconstruct the brain piece by piece.
And it's super,
super computer based model and simulation.
The project is actually the latest to be chosen by the European Commission to
receive funding as a part of the fet flagship initiatives.
So the cerebral challenge,
we'll be headed up by Switzerland's equal polytechnique,
whatever the fuck it is.
And it's estimated to cost 1.1 9 billion euros.
So what these guys are doing is they're,
they're essentially going to make an artificial brain.
Wow.
I mean,
they're spending a fuck load of money and,
uh,
sales 1.1 9 billion is that you're a part of it.
That translates to dollars is 1.6 $3 billion,
almost a,
you know,
more than one and a half billion.
And it,
they,
what they're trying to do is a,
they're at advance advanced robotics and,
um,
it's really crazy.
It's a 10 year project that's a fifth of the time
required to develop a space liner.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Oh,
that's the other thing that they're trying to build a space liner there.
Um,
yeah,
this is really crazy.
There's a,
they're going to be able to go from Europe to Australia in 90 minutes,
zero
touch by going up,
up in space.
Yeah.
There what they're going to do is,
uh,
the idea is you're going to be able to go supersonic speeds.
Um,
and you're,
you're going to be able to do it just like the Concorde was doing it,
but they're going to do it and space.
But how long would it take you just to get the space?
Um,
I don't know.
I have to,
how does the space shuttle?
It takes forever to get well,
they're saying you're going to be able to go from Europe to Australia and down
and just 90 minutes.
Wow.
That would make the whole world so much smaller.
Yeah.
They're 15 mile.
They're,
they're uh,
50 years out.
They believe 55 year five zero.
Yeah.
It's going to take a long time.
No,
you won't hang in there,
bitch.
They're going to go 150,000 miles an hour.
Stop.
And think about that a hundred thousand miles an hour.
That means you can go back and forth across the United States.
Do you know how fast we go now?
When you going to plan
500 so 500
stopping.
Thinking about that.
502.
How much?
Hundred and 50,000 miles an hour.
150,000 play right now.
We'll go twice as fast.
It would still have to go 150 times faster than that.
The issue right now,
apparently the problem is creating a design that's capable of tolerating the
heat generated at such speed.
Friction from the air.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's amazing.
How does,
and you know what,
people are still gonna Bitch about the seats.
Motherfuck can leave your seat back and it'd be gone.
$150,000.
No fucking laptop going 150,000 miles an hour.
I want to use a fucking laptop.
You fucking cock soccer.
I'll kick your seat.
All the TSA wants to check me for bombs while I go 150,000 miles an hour.
How about let me wear my sneakers.
I got a medical condition.
You fucks.
This is pretty crazy shit man.
I mean we,
we're,
we're getting a glimpse at the future and when we say 50 years we'd go,
oh,
that's so far away.
Well,
is it?
Is it really think about 1960 1960 was 50 years ago.
Well,
they look at all these natural disasters,
tsunamis and stuff,
and people are like,
Oh,
you know,
I was terrible.
But if you know,
shit happens or whatever,
and they're like,
no,
this happens every 80 years.
So all we do is we all die off and then the next generation comes in.
I'm like,
oh,
we could never see this happening.
It's like it will continue to happen.
Yeah.
They forget,
I'll quit building up the port or figure out a wall system.
There's nothing you can do if you have to choose to just roll the dice and thing
of building these breakers,
like go out in the bay out.
So it would take like,
cause some fly,
but nothing like nothing damaging at all.
I think that was the idea behind Atlanta's.
Um,
and then it fell.
Yeah.
Well the,
the rising sea levels too,
you know,
sea levels change radically over time,
especially with the,
I mean there's no sir,
there's absolutely some evidence that points to global warming in some way or
shape being affected by human beings.
Absolutely.
But even if we didn't affect 10
minutes,
even if we didn't affect it,
they've been the,
the,
the temperature of the earth is very threatened.
Changes greatly.
Like the dinosaurs whenever it was.
The universe opens and closes.
It does,
it's like a balloon or whatever.
The,
the,
you know,
the fucking son's going to brown and destroy us all anyway,
one day,
5 billion years from now,
according to our pile and to grass.
Tyson.
Neil had some amazing Superbowl quotes the other day while the people were,
uh,
well he was tweeting super bowl stuff,
but it was like cool fuckers and science super bowl stuff.
I see.
I should,
uh,
I should pull some of mob because they were fucking awesome,
man.
Let me find it.
But he's,
what is he in end Tyson on Twitter.
Neil Tyson,
Tyson.
And by the way,
everybody in North Carolina.
Um,
I'll be in Raleigh,
North Carolina this weekend.
So don't you guys don't get my special until I'm there.
Oh,
why is it the same material?
Well,
I have like 20 different material.
It's funny.
25 different.
Yeah,
it's hard,
isn't it?
But they'll still be like 25.
I'm doing some gigs just to fuck around.
Um,
specifically to work on new material.
Like I've got a few lines.
That's really smart.
Yeah.
I'm doing xannies and a Nashville,
which is a nice small club.
I'm going to do that over a whole weekend this weekend.
Um,
me,
Brian and Joey Diaz are going to be in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
You fuckheads giant room.
Yeah,
it's giant.
It's awesome though.
It's a great room and tickets are selling very fast.
It's almost sold out most of the show,
so that'll be cool.
Get on that shit freaks.
I liked these markers.
You have that your draw is getting better where you've returned to a place.
Like in Calgary we did that Jack singer Paul,
and it was like,
we filled it up eventually.
We got it filled up the first time.
This time two shows sold out in advance.
Yeah.
And it was like,
wow,
that's a clear sign of stuff getting better.
You just sold out Montreal and like 50 minutes didn't issue or something like
that.
I heard that.
Well that was like a small,
it's,
it's my friend Jim Vose club because I was just there a couple months ago and I
did a big theater.
Uh,
I did,
um,
I forgot this metropolis is a tropical.
Yeah.
Big Ass fucking place,
like a couple of thousand people.
So from that to two,
this is a,
I did a Jim Jimbos place because first of all,
I love Jimbo.
I've been working for him.
It goes off.
Yeah.
It's a crazy little club.
80 people in a room.
It should seat 40.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
It's just such a great experience.
It's great.
And a,
it's going to be you and me,
right?
You're doing it.
Yeah.
We're going to have to say it's going to be such a good time.
It's going to be so fun and it,
the place couldn't be cooler in the pub downstairs is amazing.
Everybody works here as cool as fuck.
And a lot of the same guys that have been working there since the beginning of
time.
So let me,
this is our tender.
Some of the tweets,
the tweets that,
uh,
he,
he wrote about,
uh,
if grid irons were Tom Neil degrasse Tyson wrote this.
If grid irons were timelines with the big bang at one goal and then from caveman
to now with span the thickness of a single turf blade at the other goal.
Isn't that amazing?
Like you would go from the big bang through the entire football field and then
one turf flavor caveman to us would be one blade of grass.
Wow.
One tiny thing that you can't even see when you're looking at it.
Yeah,
he's super bowl.
He's cool as fuck.
We'll have to get him back in here again and I proved it.
Landing Talk.
Yeah.
Well if we could,
I believe he's a,
he's in New York resident,
but he's out here doing the new version of the cosmos,
which is going to be fucking amazing.
And he just hit a million twitters,
Twitter followers.
So follow him.
It's Neil Tyson,
n e I l Tyson on Twitter.
And you could fall Ari Shaffir and if you work for the Tsa you can give him a
rash of shit.
Fuck,
I'm going to try to be calmer.
Ff I are,
he's going to be calmer.
But uh,
you can get revenge for the Holocaust.
This is the CD and it's available right now to get them together.
They had these bundles so you can get a poster or the CD and on the special
offer.
So you get two hours of juicy fucking rhe fear material.
Go get some.
You're dirty Fox and a if you want to see juicy red band and juicy Joey Coco
Diaz was pompous.
It's harder and harder to get Joey Coco Diaz to open for me folks,
cause the dude is just blowing up.
We start on no for you even show up.
It's working around.
This podcast has done so much for all of us,
but Joey is a fucking monster now.
I mean he's,
he's really taken off like crazy this coming weekend.
You're in the restaurant?
Yeah,
this coming weekend.
Can't wait.
Your Fox and a yeah.
If you bought my special recently on Joe rogan.net it will be 100% new material.
None of that material is on.
I already have an hour and 20 minutes of new shit because I don't play bitches.
Okay.
I got an isolation tank in my basement.
That's really good too.
Thanks man.
I'm,
I'm excited about it.
There's a couple of stuff's really good.
Vegan,
Bitsa,
favorite.
My favorite bit of ever around my favorite.
It's my favorite.
So glad I'm so that that is partly in faithful to you because you reminded me of
that pit.
You know,
you reminded me of that bit.
Actually I got to give you 100% credit cause I probably would have forgotten who
wrote it.
Kicked some credit.
Okay.
Credit for its resurgence.
But it's even good.
It's even better now that way.
Better now the girl with the no vagina.
So
folks,
we're going to have some fucking fun.
All right.
And we will see you tomorrow night with our friends.
The real Rick Ross,
the root cause,
the real Rick Ross is not a rapper.
I know you didn't know that,
but you're gonna know that if you didn't know that already,
he's a great guy.
And when you've got some cool shit to talk to him about it,
he's just,
he's a really interesting guy.
Used to be a big time drug dealers.
Now he's a community activist and just a really cool,
nice sweet guy to talk to.
And I'm psyched to sit down and talk to them.
And there's a dude out there using this name,
that big fat Rick Ross got a wrapper.
That guy's not,
he's not real real was William Roberts.
It's not Rick Ross.
The real Rick Ross was a drug kingpin went to jail for selling cocaine during
the Iran contra scan.
You know,
the Iran Contra scandal,
you know,
you know how the uh,
the,
they were selling coke and they were using the money to fund the,
uh,
the,
you know,
the war,
the consciousness versus uh,
the Sandinistas.
That was Rick Ross.
He's the one who sold the code was the one who was selling a coke on the streets
in La.
Yes.
Yeah.
So like you've had the governor for coke and then sell it.
There was a middle man.
He didn't realize it at the time,
but it was his coke selling.
I mean,
he was selling millions of dollars.
Like,
what'd you cook?
This looks good stuff because funding covert operations overseas,
he's amazing.
He's a patriot,
really,
in a way.
If you think we should've gone there.
I couldn't even read at the time.
It was amazing.
He was making millions dollars and he couldn't read and went to jail and learned
how to read and became a lawyer in jail.
He said,
fascinating.
Fascinating guy.
He'll be on tomorrow.
All right.
You dirty freak.
That's an aggressive,
please go ahead and work alternative.
There will be no podcast.
I'm going,
I'm going out of town for the week.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go to the fucking woods,
my friend.
Oh yeah.
I'm going to find my space.
I am to go to Japan.
I'm going to meditate,
but what?
I'm not going to do step foot inside this place.
I'd take a week off.
Right,
right.
So,
yeah.
uh,
so,
I want you to take a week off and listen to all Ari's podcast and then I want
you to find him on Twitter and yell at him and awesome.
Yeah.
I have a sports car costs for his podcasts called punchdrunk with tripling and
Tivo and I am a regular podcast called skeptic tank socket.
All right,
we will see you dirty freaks,
uh,
tomorrow.
Thank you to audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe and get yourself
free 30 days and one free audio book books will make you smarter.
They will you're freaks.
And thanks to onnit.com go to o n n I t and use a code name Rogan.
You will save yourself 10% of any and all supplemental products.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll see you freak soon.
And we love the shit out of you.
We love you more than love yourself.
Thank you for coming out to see us.
Get it together,
bitches.
Okay?
Oh.